Hello everybody!
I am, I am a mess right now.
But when am I not a mess?
That's a good question.
I literally, I literally just installed Fortnite, like, my installation of Fortnite just stopped, like, finished like 10 minutes ago.
Because I forgot I didn't, I didn't install Fortnite on this PC yet.
Anyway, um, we have our Fortnite bodyguard, Doryu.
Um, he plays Fortnite a lot.
By the way, I need you guys to know, um, I had, I had, like, three other Fortnite pros that were supposed to play with me.
But then they, like, I don't know, I think they found out I wasn't a Fortnite player and they tried to...
So I'm glad Doryu didn't drop out.
I didn't, I didn't drop out.
Let me tell you a story.
So they asked me, the staff, Twitch staff asked me, um, asked me if, like, if I was willing to join the Fortnite Twitch Rivals.
And I was like, how sweaty is it?
And then they were like, oh, it's pretty sweaty.
And I was like, um...
And I was like, uh, um, can you give me a Fortnite pro?
I can, I can do it, but, like, I think I need a Fortnite pro.
And they're like, don't worry, we got you.
Um, so then, so then three, I, we had three different people that we asked.
And, like, yeah.
Because I was like, hey, um, I don't know about this.
Seems like this, I thought, you know, there'd be, like, people like me, you know?
I thought there'd be, like, people like me.
And then I looked at the roster.
And then, because, like, some, one of them suggested, the staff suggested me to recruit this player.
And I looked up this person's Twitter.
And they were, like, a, a fucking Fortnite professional.
And then they're, and they're recruiting for their Fortnite Twitch Rivals.
They were, like, looking for a pro Fortnite pro player.
For a Twitch Rivals.
And I'm like, but he's already pro.
What, what do you mean?
Why, why is he looking for a Fortnite pro if he's already pro?
I thought it'd be, like, you know, non-pro with pro.
And then I was like, hey, are there any other teams, like, like me?
And they're like, no, don't worry.
There's an Overwatch team as well.
There's, like, two Overwatch players together.
Um, and a team together.
Um, so they're just like you.
And I'm like, okay.
But I looked at it and it's J3 and Apply.
Apply is an, you know, has been an Overwatch cup.
J3 has been top 500 for, like, since Overwatch began.
So I was just like, oh.
I was just like, oh.
And then we, and then finally we got it.
And we got an Overwatch pro.
Uh, not Overwatch pro.
We got Fortnite.
We got, we got a Fortnite pro.
Um, we got a Fortnite pro.
And literally, we met up.
We were like, hey, I'm not a, I'm a, I'm not a Fortnite player.
Is that okay?
And then the guy was like, oh, don't worry.
It's okay.
Uh, don't worry.
We got this.
I was like, oh, thank God.
Okay.
Um, and then, like, literally, like, 15 minutes later, I got a message from the staff.
It was like, we need to find a new player.
And I was like, what happened?
And then, and then the, and then the, the guy that was supposed to be my duo messaged me and was like, I'm sorry.
We had, I had a family emergency.
I have to drop out.
I was like, we met for 15 minutes.
I was like, what?
Finally, we met for 15 minutes and then you got a family emergency?
I just, what is my luck?
What is my luck?
Um, and that was like an hour before, an hour before Twitch Rivals, um, an hour before Twitch Rivals start.
So luckily we managed to get, we managed to get Doryu, who plays a lot of Fortnite.
Um, and I was like, that's my new bodyguard.
I have a new bodyguard.
I finally have.
I have another.
I have a new bodyguard.
It took us a while, but we got another Fortnite bodyguard.
Um, so I hope I'll live long enough in this tournament.
I, I can't believe I, I, the, the 15 minute part was the most absurd.
Literally, we were in a group chat with me and the Twitch staff and the other pro.
I was like, hey, I don't play Fortnite.
And then we were discussing drops too.
They're like, oh yeah.
What, what place do you want to land?
And I was like, oh, I don't know.
You can pick it.
Pretend.
I know like I'm captain by name, but like you can, you can decide everything.
And then 15 minutes later, family emergency.
Um, so my, my Fortnite bodyguard is an actual wolf.
Um, we can't lose this.
We literally have an actual werewolf.
So like, we can't lose this.
It's like that ZZZ game, right?
Where people were thirsting over that wolf boy.
Like, like I have a wolf boy too.
So like, we'll be fine.
It's just like that wolf boy.
I have zero context of like what, what that guy is.
But like...
But like, if that, if ZZZ can survive with a wolf boy.
Maybe I can survive with all of them.
I'm also a wolf boy.
All right.
Okay.
I'm going to, I don't know where we're starting.
I'm going to unmute.
Hey.
Who are you?
Are we supposed to?
Do we have the code for the game yet?
Or like...
No, not yet.
I'm like watching it right now.
Everyone is...
I think still like getting situated.
Oh, that's great.
Okay.
Yeah.
That's good.
I'm watching the general chat right now.
Okay.
That's good.
Anyway.
Did you read the rules?
Because there's a lot of rules.
And I read one paragraph and I was like, I already tuned it out.
So I assume...
Yeah, your brain was just like...
I already tuned...
No, it's so long.
Like, why is the rule so long?
I don't...
Let me be your guide wolf.
I will be the slightly lesser smooth brain.
All right.
Yeah.
Like, it's so long.
Okay.
That's for day two.
Oh, nevermind.
Yeah.
No, day two is crazy.
But day one is not too bad.
We're not going to make it.
So that's fine.
I was literally telling Cha.
I'm like, I'm in it for the vibes.
I am probably going to die so fucking fast.
It is going to be tragic.
My Cha was like, you have great confidence.
I'm like, no.
Okay.
Doryo, you don't understand.
Like, I told them the story of like how we ended up getting you.
Like, I didn't...
I told them the story of like how we ended up getting you.
But basically, I had...
I had three different Fortnite pros that dropped out.
Are you serious?
No fucking way.
And then the last Fortnite pro...
The last...
Like, they were all Twitch assigned too.
They were trying to like assign me a pro player.
Because I was like, please, I need a Fortnite pro.
Like, if you want me at this tournament, I'm not going to survive.
Like...
No, okay.
I feel your pain.
I'm not going to survive.
Oh my god.
I'm like, I'm not going to survive.
And then...
And then like...
And then so like...
I told them like the last Fortnite pro.
Like, I literally...
We got in a group chat.
It was like an hour before the tournament.
Before Twitch Rivals.
And we were like in a group chat.
Like, we got them at like 12 or something.
12 p.m.
And then...
Yeah, yeah.
And then like...
And then we were like talking.
I was like, hey, I don't play Fortnite.
Is that okay?
And then he was like, yeah, that's fine.
It's cool.
And then...
And then we were like, yeah, where do you want to drop?
It's like, I don't care.
I don't...
I don't know what I'm doing.
Like, this is all on you, man.
And then 15 minutes later, he messaged me.
I was like, sorry, family emergency.
I can't do it.
What?
Wait.
No.
What?
I was like, what?
Did their family emergency not be a family emergency?
Like, literally right before the not family emergency event?
I was like, am I?
Did they just found out?
Like, wait.
No.
She's bad.
Bad.
All right, guys.
We are back.
Oh my god.
It was like a phone in a family emergency.
No.
Okay.
Did they even know that you used to play Apex?
Like, I said, I was like, oh, I'm gonna Apex Overwatch player.
And then...
But I honestly think it was it could be what could be a family emergency, but like the timing that was fucking crazy.
Yeah.
50 minutes after it, like I don't know, like realization struck for him and he's like, wait a minute.
Dead.
I was fucking dead ass.
I was fucking brushing my teeth.
Checking my phone.
And you messaged me.
And I had fucking bed head and everything.
Oh my god.
I was like, please.
I need somebody that knows how to play Fortnite.
You give me too much credit.
I know how to die very fast in this game.
What do you mean?
There's clips of you.
No, are you done?
You're supposed to be my bodyguard.
You were like the last hope.
I went through all of them.
I don't remember this episode of Fortnite.
What is it called?
Is it literally like Dory, the last protector?
In reality, he's actually a big inting... You're supposed to be my bodyguard.
You're literally a weapon.
I'll eat the bullets.
No, you're not supposed to eat the bullets.
You're supposed to kill them.
We're doomed.
Oh no, it's okay.
We're not going to make it to day two.
It's okay.
What if we make it to day two?
What if we're lured off the board?
Then God actually hates us.
And God said, let there be VTubers and furry VTubers.
Oh my god.
You have sinned.
I fucking... we're fucked.
Okay.
Jokey, we ready.
We fucking ready.
Oh my god.
All right.
Okay, they have the code.
We're supposed to...
Oh yeah.
We're supposed to be in a party together.
Yeah, here.
Let me invite you.
All right.
Okay.
Also, are you Peter Griffin?
No, I'm John Cena now, so they can't see me.
I do have Peter Griffin, though.
Should I be Peter?
Wait, I could be Peter.
I could be whatever Chat wants me to be.
Wait, wait, wait.
What is Chat going to make you?
Because then I can be something to match you.
Well, I have Meeseeks, too.
No, you have Meeseeks.
Yeah, I have Meeseeks.
We could be Rick and Meeseeks.
Do you have Rick?
I don't have...
Yeah, I have Rick.
Wait, you have Rick?
Oh my god.
Yeah, I'm being Rick.
Wait, wait, wait.
That's great.
Okay, wait.
How do I...
Wait, wait.
How do I go back to...
Wait, am I not?
Oh, wait.
Am I not?
Join party.
Okay.
Oh my god.
You have Morty.
I have Morty.
Oh my god.
Same character.
Okay, okay.
Morty and Meeseeks.
Okay, they'll know who to kill first.
That's great.
They'll know...
They'll know who to get for easy points.
That's how we're gonna send the message.
I think I need to...
Okay, let me enter the code real quick.
Yeah, yeah.
You do the code entering.
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
Okay, I got you.
I got you.
So guys, how's Doryu?
Is Doryu's volume okay?
Yeah, same for you guys, chat.
Can you guys hear Doki fine?
Yeah, yeah.
Can you hear Doryu okay?
And can you hear me okay?
As long as I'm loud in Doryu, that's all that matters.
But also, you can't be like...
You can't...
Can't hear him.
Yeah, yeah.
My brain is still booting up.
I literally got home like 30 minutes ago to install Fortnite.
Deadass.
Oh my god.
Doryu, we're so ready.
We are so fucking ready.
We're so ready.
Okay, hit ready.
A tad though.
I think I got it good.
Okay, let me...
We're good.
I'm gonna boost you up a little bit.
And then...
All right.
Okay, I boosted you up.
Chat, I got Morty on his back.
Or I got Rick on his back, okay?
We got Pickle.
Pickle.
Pickle Rick.
Oh, you got Pickle Rick?
Yeah, I got Pickle Rick on his back.
Wait, I think I have Pickle Rick too.
Wait, do you really?
Yo, let's go.
Wait, actually, I don't know.
I buy a lot of stuff.
I have the snake...
The pickaxe for the snake.
Oh, you got the snake pickaxe too?
Yo, I'm gonna put that.
I got Pickle Rick.
Let's go.
Yo.
I'm fucking doing it.
I'm doing it.
Guys, you have to be like at a certain IQ to understand this.
Let's see.
Wait, wait, wait.
What's it called?
It's called the snake?
Yeah.
Okay, there it is.
There it is.
I got it.
All right.
We're still fucking back.
Funniest shit ever, guys.
Oh, we are fucking in this.
They ain't even ready.
Yeah, yeah.
They know we're a great team and we're, like, matching.
We got the drip.
Exactly.
Am I supposed to ready up?
Oops.
Yeah, yeah.
Go ahead and ready up.
Yeah.
All right.
We're fine.
By the way, I was watching.
I was checking your stream out because we went live earlier and you were doing game training.
Yeah, yeah.
I just want you to know.
I was doing the stream.
I was definitely not doing any of that.
Yo, but were you doing food training?
Because I'm about to get hungry.
I was definitely not warming up.
The last time I shot the pew-pew was at four in the morning two days ago.
Because I was ringing for an apex scrim.
Yo.
Wait, you were doing apex scrims?
No, no.
It was for, like, somebody's, like...
It was for a Japanese tournament.
So, like, I was ringing for somebody.
Oh, my gosh.
Wait, who are you going to be playing?
Man, can you believe we haven't played apex since, like, three years ago?
I think that's, like, three or four years ago.
Three or four years ago?
When we did that apex rank grind.
Yeah, we ancient.
We ancient.
Yeah, we're fucking old.
Yeah, you used to still be...
You weren't a werewolf yet.
You used to be full fleshy.
I used to be a gross human flesh tuber.
Yeah, and then you got bit by a wolf.
Yeah, you guys won't get bit by a wolf.
And now you got that dog in you.
I mean, you didn't get bit by a wolf.
You was that 0-0...
You were that ZZZ wolf before ZZZ came out.
Oh, husbando.
Oh, man.
Wait, you're, like, 30-something, right?
Yeah, I'm, like...
I'm ancient AFM.
Oh, my God.
You're old, old.
Yeah, I'm, like, literally old, old.
Oh, my God.
I'm, like, crusty, crusty.
I invented the crusty crab.
That's all I'm saying.
Holy shit.
Oh, my God.
Yo, how did you ever...
How did you befriend a crusty-ass, crusty crab like me?
April.
I was, like, in Apex.
I don't remember.
We, like...
I think, like, it was, like, a friend of a friend in Apex.
I think it was Apex.
And then we just, like, played in ranked.
Because we need...
Oh, I think it was, like, a rank.
Because, like, we needed a plus one or something.
Yeah, it was ranked.
Yeah, we needed a plus one.
I don't know if it was you who needed a plus one or I needed a plus one, but we were granting rank or something for Apex.
Wait, was that, like, LFG back then?
Was it LFG?
Like, in Apex Discord?
I don't remember.
I actually don't.
I feel like it might have been.
I feel like it might...
It could have been.
I think it was through a friend.
Because, like, I remember one of us needed, like, a plus one for ranked.
Yeah.
And then, like, we needed...
We were trying to get Pred or something.
And, like, we were just LFG-ed or...
Like, we just, like...
Like, we, like...
Oh, I know some...
Like, a mutual friend was, like, we know somebody.
And it was, like...
Yeah.
You or me.
God, like...
Wait, was it you that tweeted that clip from Apex days?
Yeah, yeah.
When we were, like, fucking WK?
When we were, like, meeting you and saying...
And we, like, fucking killed, like, some fucking pro-Pred team.
Yeah.
And they were, like, what...
Because I didn't...
I stopped grinding rank at that time.
So, I was plat.
Yeah, yeah.
And then he was, like, who the fuck is this plat player?
Doki Bird.
Who the fuck is she?
Or they don't even say, is he?
Who the fuck is he?
We were being so gremlin.
We were so gremlin to that.
Yeah, because they were, like, he's plat.
What the fuck?
Yeah, look at...
Look at this plat Doki.
Doki Bird looking ass.
Yeah, yeah.
Because we shit on them.
They were literally, like, top 10 Pred or whatever.
Damn.
Oh, my God.
I've not been playing Apex at all.
I'm still watching Apex.
I'm still watching that game now.
Oh, sorry.
Same here.
Doki, we in this.
We in this.
Wait.
Where are you?
I don't know.
I'm still connecting.
Oh, my God.
It's us.
Look.
We are in Pickle Rick.
Pickle Rick.
Wait.
What emotes you got?
I don't remember.
What button is it?
I think I'd be on mine.
Oh, shit.
We're, like, going.
Where's your drop spot?
We're going here.
So, land on the blue mark.
No.
Okay.
I'm going to go here.
And I'm going to get all the loot from that.
And I'll run over to you.
Oh, so I land on the red, right?
Yeah.
You land on the red.
Okay.
Guys, is Dory's volume better now?
Or does he need to be lifted up more?
Yay.
Let's go.
All right.
I have no idea what the equipments are.
So...
Oh, there's the plunger gun.
Literally run everything and anything you want to run.
Okay.
Cool.
And then you do everything else.
Basically.
I'll just exist.
Yeah.
I'll exist.
As long as I'm alive, then, like, we've already accomplished a lot.
You have...
You know, like, about shields and stuff, though.
Yeah?
Yeah.
Okay.
Cool.
Yeah.
I know.
I know about shields.
I have cosmetics.
So, at least I know that.
That's awesome.
Yay!
Wow!
What did I do?
Oh, there's a little trampoline.
All right.
I got all my loot over here.
So, I'm gonna, like, run through here.
Wait.
I got a fucking trampoline thing.
Oh, those are really, really good.
I think I've seen where you used it.
The thing...
Oh, yeah.
If you double jump, it, like, auto-deploys it, which is really annoying.
Because I was like, what the fuck?
How did that happen?
Wait.
How do I...
I was watching the house.
I'm gonna try to find us, like...
So, you know, in build mode, everyone turns into...
Like, a freaking tower or whatever.
Yeah.
By the way, I have...
I dropped a plen...
A grappler.
We want it.
Oh, you don't want that?
I don't think I can use it.
I don't think it's smart for me to use it.
Do you want to use shockwaves?
Do you know how to use shockwaves?
What's shockwaves?
It's the purple thing that basically, like, launches you into the air.
Oh, yeah.
No.
It's, like, the pathfinder grapple in this game.
Any movement stuff, do not rely on me for this game.
Okay.
I...
Look, my job is to exist.
Wait, you want the plunder gun?
Yeah, I'll take the plunder gun.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
No.
Take it.
What do I drop?
What do I drop, though?
Oh, wait.
What guns are you using?
I have...
Okay.
I'll drop...
I have one gun.
Do you want a shotgun?
No.
I'll take this gun.
This gun is tracking.
I can track.
Yo.
Okay.
I don't know what any of those words are.
The RNG in the bullets is very very bad.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Oh, bloom bloom as in FPS...
I thought it was, like, a Fortnite word.
I thought you are using a Fortnite word on me.
I...
It must be like, no.
No.
Orlando Bloom is atrocious, because he is going to be in the co lab very soon.
Okay.
So, Zone is closing.
And...
Wait.
What the hell.
We're right next to it.
We're next to the zone.
Oh, hey, there it is!
Oh, there's a chest here!
Yeah!
Oh, okay, so... do you see these little bunkers right here on the ground?
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, I know the port-a-bunkers!
Grab those.
It's okay.
We're right next to the zone.
I'm gonna slash this thing.
Okay.
Yeah.
Alright, let's go to the right?
Alright, sure.
Let's go through here.
Whee!
Come here, Meeseeks!
Oh my god!
Wait!
Somebody's dead!
We're not last!
No, we're not last!
We're vibing!
We're fucking vibing right now.
Oh, we're not last!
Thank you!
We're actually vibing.
Let's fucking go!
We're doing so much already!
Yo, all we gotta do is exist, okay?
That's all we have to do.
That's how we already got points for not being last!
Let's go!
Yeah, we're fucking chillin' right now.
We were...
We should, like, change our sins every game, just so they don't farm us.
I'm down!
Oh, there's a team here.
There's a team here.
I'm gonna back real quick.
Let's get around.
Let's try to beat them.
Let's be evasive.
Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let's go, like, over here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It was a condom skin.
You know the grey superhero ones?
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah!
Hold on.
They're gonna be to the right.
Oh, yeah, they see us.
They see us.
Oh, they do.
They do.
Oh, they're doing... they're jumping up.
Alright, let's keep... let's go over here.
Yeah, no, I feel like... I feel like they're... they have matching skins, too.
So they could be really, really good matching skins, or really, really bad matching skins like us.
They might be just as scared as us.
That's true.
Oh my god, I can...
If we watch it back, they're gonna be probably mirroring us over here.
There's also... oh, there's team over here.
Alright.
Let's go under the bridge.
Okay.
Let's go here.
Alright, I'm heading down with you.
I'm looking for you.
Oh, we're chilling here.
We're chilling.
Alright, nice, nice, nice.
Okay, I'm gonna... just kinda crouch here.
We can just... we can vibe.
We can vibrate here.
Ooh, I hear them shooting.
They're shooting already.
Not last.
Yeah, we're... we're chilling.
Look at me, level one and... level 100 and 46?
You said you didn't play!
I don't play this game.
What do you mean?
Level 100 and 46?
I'm really level one!
Yeah, that's scrub levels, right?
That's scrub.
What am I?
You're Mr. Meeseeks.
You got a little...
I'm level one!
What am I then?
You're... I don't know.
You're level...
Okay, can they hear that?
Oh, they definitely can't hear me.
What the fuck?
Now they know we're down here.
No, we're chilling.
I think I'd be, like, super close to it.
So, like, no, that...
We're here.
Oh, they apparently said I don't have the visual feedback.
Oh...
Oh, you don't have...
Okay, hold on.
I got an idea.
Hit escape... Oh, no, actually, don't do it.
There's people above us.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I was gonna say.
I didn't... I don't know.
You're gonna be right here?
And then I turn that off.
Okay, I'll watch for us.
I'm watching for us.
Okay.
Oh, this thing got cracked above us?
We might be able to get them if they, like...
Drop down?
38?
Wait, what?
What?
They are right above us.
We're gonna put pressure on them if they try to, like...
Don't look down.
Oh, we're gonna have to move, so... Oh, fuck, I have a crown!
I'm so dumb!
Wait, you have a crown?
What's that?
Yeah, I do not want this crown.
Oh, that means I won the last game.
Oh, wait, they didn't turn that off!
That's so unfair!
Wait, wait, wait, oh, Doki Doki, come here, come here, come here, come here, come here.
Look at this, look at this, look at this.
Yeah.
We can shoot these guys in the back.
3, 2, 1, the one on the left.
Yeah.
Oh, no, never mind, okay.
Okay, okay.
Okay, well, we're gonna go to the left then.
Goodbye!
Oh, yep, I'm gonna do this.
Oh, okay.
I'm gonna do this again, and I'm gonna splash us.
Nice.
Oh my god, that was quick reaction.
You want my portal bunker?
Uh, carry... you sure you don't want to carry it?
No, I'm pretty sure.
Okay.
Okay, so...
Follow me here, follow me, follow me.
We're gonna crouch, we're gonna go to the side.
Am I crouching?
No.
Yeah, there you go, there you go.
Okay, get ready, and we're gonna run in 3, 2, 1, let's start going.
Okay.
We're gonna see his team in a sec.
Oh, they're right in front.
I'm gonna get on here.
We're gonna shoot on the left.
Uh, okay.
Doki, we're gonna have to go over here.
Okay.
So, stand right on me, stand right on me.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, we're gonna get shot in the back.
What the fuck are they doing here?
Come on, I got us, I got us, I got us.
Okay.
Uh, okay, so...
Yeah?
Do you know how to shockwave yourself?
We'll find out.
Take that thing and use it like a Pathfinder.
Grab it.
Okay.
All right, time to fight.
Wait, do it at your feet?
Like this?
Oh, shit!
Oh, did I knock you?
No!
No, I'm not done until you knock me.
Ohh...
I have 16!
Oh yeah.
I think you shocked me into the other team!
No!
Its nations a condom skin!
Every...
slave!
That was all part of the plan.
It was going to be an evasive shockwave and then we're going to go...
That was part of the plan.
What was the plan?
Oh, they have the apex thing now.
They have that thing.
Wait, you had the grapple.
Oh, I had the plunger grapple.
I could have used that.
They're using my...
They're using my plunger...
Oh, that's where you died.
Yeah, that's where I died at.
Yeah, yeah.
See these skins?
These are what we call the condom skins.
Oh, cool.
Wait, so you do play Fortnite.
You know all the lingo.
You know the lingo.
Yeah, Chad, do you guys know about the condom skins?
Wait, okay, so how do I turn on the audio feedback?
So, under settings, go to...
Oh, let's see.
Is it the very last one?
No, no, no.
I think it's under...
Oh, where is it?
I gotta find it again.
Is it visual sound effects?
Yeah, yeah, it's that one.
Just turn that on.
Alright, alright, we're good.
We're good to go.
Guys.
Yo, we weren't dead last.
Yeah, we're not last.
How many teams are in it?
I think it's 40 teams, I think.
Whoa, we did it all the way?
It's 20 teams.
You should have lied and said 40 so I felt happier.
Let me look at the team numbers.
Yeah, out of 20 teams?
We were...
I think...
12?
No, we were 16.
We played 16.
Oh, you're right.
Yeah, we were 16.
I'm like, there's numbers on the top.
There's literally a number right there at the top.
There's literally a number at the top.
I was like, where did you get the 12 from?
I'm like over here looking at Discord like, oh, let me put on my nerd glasses real quick.
I got them.
Alright.
Let me... okay.
My audio guy said turn you down just a little bit and then boost up the audio.
So give me a sec.
I'm gonna turn you down just a little bit.
And then... alright, guys.
Does the game sound a lot better, chat?
Is it... does the game sound a lot better?
How does Doki sound to you guys too?
Is Doki pretty okay?
Thank you so much, Bob.
Thank you.
Alright.
I just have to make sure.
Alright, guys.
That was our warm up game.
Yeah, that was a warm up.
That was literally the warm up game.
That was a warm up, chat.
I had literally no idea what I'm doing.
I still don't, but like now...
At least...
At least, like, I know a little bit more.
That's all that matters.
What the fuck?
They said no build.
Who the fuck put all these portal bunkers?
Yo, fucking... This is what I tell chat all the time.
I'm like...
How is it no build if there's bunkers?
Thank you.
That's counterintuitive to no building!
Because you're still building a bunker!
I literally complain about this all the time.
I'm like... I love zero build.
Wait.
I love...
Oh my god!
That's how you do... Oh my god!
That's how you do the jump.
Oh, it doesn't matter.
She's still dead.
Yeah, you like...
You throw a... You basically throw... It's like a grenade.
You like throw it at your feet, and then it'll launch you wherever direction that your character is standing on.
Oh!
I see.
But the nice thing about this mode is that...
It responded... Did you ever play Three Strikes?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's like Three Strikes.
It's like Three Strikes in Fortnite.
Yeah.
So, as long as one person's still alive, we're chillin'.
These guys are such nerds.
They're doing like same skin.
They're not...
I know, right?
You can do like matching themes.
That's like... You know how like...
Um... Like...
Like beta... Betas use same skin.
Alpha and Sigma males use matching themes.
Yeah, I don't see any like... There's no chat right now.
Everyone's just a condom.
Same skin is boring.
It's all about the theme.
It's the theming of the skin.
Wait, do you have Dragon Ball skins?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I have... Yo!
I have all the good ones.
Which one do you want?
Do you have all the good... all of them as well?
I think I do, yeah.
I'm pretty sure I have all the... Well, all the first wave?
Because I think they did a second wave of like...
I have like... I have Frieza and Cell and Vegeta.
What?
You have Frieza and Cell?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I have Frieza and Cell.
I have Goku, too, I think.
Oh, I'm so jelly.
Okay, I don't have Frieza, but I do have Goku and like Vegeta and stuff.
Oh, okay.
Wait, we could do Goku and Vegeta.
I got Team Big Forehead.
Oh, my God.
Okay, do we want to do the...
Or we do villains.
Do we want to do Villain Hero or just the heroes?
Uh, I'm down.
I'm down for villains.
Villain Hero?
Okay, I can do Frieza and you can be Goku.
Alright.
The teamwork of the century.
The collab of the century.
Frieza and Goku working together in Fortnite to beat the Fortnite players.
Kakarot, I must beat Fortnite players.
I can't believe it.
The team up.
They teamed up together so they can beat Fortnite.
I never foresaw this happening.
If you ever asked me in the past.
I can't believe it.
The ending we all wanted.
It's the dream duo.
The tournament of power loss episode.
Let's go!
I am so happy that out of all the teams that are playing in this tourney no one is ready for team Kakarot and Vegeta.
Yeah, yeah.
No, we're Frieza.
Frieza, I mean.
Yeah, Frieza.
How could you?
Fake fan.
No!
No, not like this!
You're a fake fan!
You try to pretend you're a real fan by using Kakarot!
But you're a fake fan!
You mistaken Frieza with Vegeta!
Yeah, I'm more of a Naruto fan.
I can't believe it!
I have not watched Dragon Ball since I think uh...
Z?
What was after Z?
They did GT on Cartoon Network.
GT, which is not Which is not canon.
Yeah, which is not canon and doesn't exist in Dragon Ball eyes.
I know one person that has stood by GT being amazing and otherwise everyone has sinned against it.
Wait, you think GT is amazing?
Me?
No, no, I do not think so.
Oh, okay, okay, I was going to say, then we know you're an actual fake fan.
I haven't even watched it!
I remember when, when you know, in Dragon Ball, they Dragon Balled and then they like, did the Z thing and then, you know, when Naruto What the fuck is the Z thing?
What is the Z thing in your world?
Like what?
Holy shit, this guy's a Fortnite player.
Oh, you want to know what Z means?
You want to know how I got the fucking Z?
Yeah.
It's literally because someone took Doryu on Twitch.
Oh, so then you're like Doryu Z.
Yeah, so like, everyone, everyone who's like, yo, what's the cool lore to your name?
I'm like, I couldn't take my original name.
You're just Z.
That's my lore.
Big Dragon Ball fan over here.
I was like, um, his name is Naruto.
Goku is his dad.
You know when Bulma, like, did the Bulma thing and then... Yeah, you know when Bulma and Sakura, like, worked together to rescue Boruto, and um, and then after that, that like, Bleached Man came over and... Yeah.
I can't believe, I can't I can't believe... Sasuke Kurosake.
Yeah, yeah, and then like, Sasuke came over with Luffy, the something, uh, to help and find the One Piece.
That's it, right?
You know, I was hurting my brain by trying to formulate all these thoughts, but like, we're hurting our brain collectively as a team right now.
Wait, Bleach Man's name isn't Bleach?
He has an actual name?
Yeah, you know, his name is Man Bleach, or John Bleach.
Oh, it's John Bleach Man, right?
John Bleach Man, yeah.
Yeah, when he carries that big-ass gun.
You know?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And he's out there... from that one Final Fantasy game.
And he's out there to find the Dragon Balls.
Yeah, and then, uh, he throws the Dragon Balls and then it summons Ifrit, right?
Yeah, yeah, he summons Vegeta.
Oh, yeah, I remember that.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, that was such a good episode.
That's like the big-ass monkey.
Vegeta, the monkey.
Oh, you mean...
Tarzan?
Wait, they made Japanese Tarzan?
You know, they probably did.
They probably did.
There's just a fanfic of, like, anime Tarzan.
And then they saved the world!
I guarantee you someone is searching it right now on, like, DeviantArt.
If DeviantArt even still is alive.
This is how I lost all my fans.
By butchering five different big fandoms in anime.
Five of the biggest anime fandoms ever.
But we didn't slander Evangelion yet, though.
Which I actually just watched.
I literally just watched it for the first time.
Yeah, we just watched it.
Did you realize, like, the company went bankrupt recently?
Wait, what?
No!
Yeah, for, like, for, like, money laundering or something.
Oh, wait, are you talking about Studio Trigger or the studio behind it?
The studio, the original studio behind it.
They, like, Jesus Christ, what the fuck am I watching?
Why is there a fucking easter egg head?
There's an easter egg head.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
He just died years ago, but they officially died recently.
Like, as in, like, I think, like, there was a news article saying they just, like, recently got, like, a sentence or whatever.
What?
Like, the directors for the behind, the CEO behind.
Oh my god, the condom men won!
Yo, what?
The condom men?
There's several condom men?
Yo.
There's several condom men.
So fucking sweaty.
I feel like when the condom skins get put on, you know that, like, clown image of the guy in the mirror, like, putting the makeup on?
It's like the condom skins, like, it's time to go to work.
Why do you think they're so cool?
Other games don't think you're cool with the condom men skin.
They think you're fucking nerds.
You're basically the bald wraith of Apex.
That's not a compliment.
I have always called him the bald wraith of Apex.
I fucking love you.
Yeah, you can be exactly.
Someone's like, you can literally be Goku.
Why would you be a condom?
Exactly!
That's what I'm saying.
How do we back out?
Return to lobby?
Yeah, I think we back out.
Yeah, return to lobby.
Alright, I'm gonna be...
You can literally be... You can be Eddie!
You can be the fucking people in Lethal Company!
They literally added Lethal Company!
And for that, you decided to be a condom?
No, I wanna be a condom.
What the fuck is wrong with you?
Anyway, I'm gonna be Frieza.
Alright.
So, and I'm being Vegeta, right?
Yeah, yeah.
No, no.
Goku, Goku.
Oh, I'm gonna be Goku.
Okay.
Alright, let's see what's in the shop.
What the fuck is this?
The signature style?
What the...
Do you see that?
The mad mochi outfit?
Oh, is it the big, like, the thing that looks like they're from Super Mario?
What?
Mad mochi?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, like the build-up.
A tall, like, mochi ball man.
Yeah!
Like, what the fuck is wrong with you?
You can literally be a mad mochi person.
Oh my god, I thought you were Lando Bloom!
Yeah, Lando Bloom is literally in here!
Guys, by the way, if you wanna support a creator, you can use Doki Bird right here.
So, um, when you buy stuff... Yeah, use Doki Bird!
Doki Bird!
Oh, chat, use code Doki.
Yeah, yeah, Doki Bird.
Doki Bird, Doki Bird.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh my god, so we can... Lady Gaga's in here?!
Yeah, they have Lady Gaga and they have Ariana Grande.
Oh my god, I was so behind!
I was so...
The only thing I remember from it was the Lethal Company men.
Doki, the night is young.
We can literally play so many combos.
Oh my god!
There's like... Oh, they added more Marvel characters.
Yeah, we could literally be Thanos and, like, Black Widow.
Or we could be...
Oh my god!
Lady Gaga with... I can't believe Pius the Caribbean is in here!
Right?
What the fuck?
They're doing a big update on Friday, where they're gonna add, uh, a bunch of, like, Pirates of the Caribbean stuff.
Oh!
And they're adding in this, like, pirate ship movement item, where, like, you basically What?!
Yeah, I think you, like, summon a ghost pirate ship.
You're gonna summon a ghost pirate ship?
What the fuck?
Yeah, yeah.
Isn't that broken?
Does that seem...
Does that seem... Oh, that's why Fortnite Competitive is dead.
Now...
Don't say a lot of them in the back.
Now I understand.
Cause how the fuck do you balance a giant pirate ship?
Like, how the fuck?
Alright.
Okay, I got... I think I got all the right stuff equipped right now.
Okay.
Oh, okay.
Let me see what I can equip, too.
I got Frieza.
Alright.
What are you doing in the back?
For the back?
Oh, for the back?
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, are you just gonna do...
I have the oxygen tank.
Oh, you have the oxygen tank?
Okay.
Do you have a crewmate?
Like, the little amogus?
No, I didn't buy it!
Yeah, they... I think they have that for, like, when they start selling the game on Epic, I think.
No!
I don't have it!
I have... let's see.
I have... I'll put it on Baby Bender.
Yo, you're gonna put Baby Bender?
Oh, I have Baby Bender!
I have that, too!
I'm gonna put Baby Bender, and then my pickaxe is still gonna be... I'm gonna keep my pickaxe the same, cause I don't think we're gonna be using that much often.
Yeah.
Should I put on, uh, Yoda?
I can put Yoda on my back.
Oh, is he a Baby Yoda?
Oh my god, Baby Bender!
Yeah, oh, no, no.
It's Grownass.
Grownass.
Oh, sorry.
Oh, man.
Grownass Yoda.
Oh, wait, what the fuck?
Wait, how do I... how do I turn yourself back so I can see it?
Is there a way?
Oh, hold on.
Wait, I can do an emote.
Let me do an emote real quick.
Okay, okay, I wanna see Baby Yoda.
Or, like, Grownass Yoda.
Wait, what was the emote that turns you around?
Here we go.
I think he'll jump on the back.
What the...
No, okay, never mind.
He does not jump on the back.
Wait, what about...
Uh... this one?
I can barely...
I, like, sort of see it.
I gotta find one where I just turn around.
Where's the turn around one, chat?
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh, wait, did we get the next code?
Oh, okay, we did.
We got the next code?
We did, we did, we got the next code.
Okay.
Uh...
Let me enter the...
We'll never see big Grownass Yoda.
Okay, let me... Okay, I got it.
Okay, go ahead and ready up.
Alright.
What else do I have?
I have...
I have the Macarena.
What do you have?
Wait, I have a two!
No, you got a one!
Let's fucking go!
Bring back the Sarah!
Oh my god!
The moment I saw that in the store, I needed to have it.
Have you actually watched that video again recently?
Yeah, yo, no, did you watch the video where, like, they all got together and, like, recreated it?
Yeah, they got together and recreated it!
And you can see that it's not the same because they went corporate.
Some of them became businessmen and women and you can see that the...
You can see it's not as good as before.
Life hit them hard.
Corporate hit them hard.
Wait, let me see if I can find it.
Oh my god, wait, okay.
What was it called?
Was it a golf dance?
Uh, it's called, uh, Infectious.
Oh, it's the CyberGoth dance party!
Okay, CyberGoth.
They just weren't... Oh, it's called the video, right?
CyberGoth dance reunion.
And you can tell it's not the same.
My boyfriend and I were talking about it the other day and we were like, dang, you know, everyone used to make fun of them back then and then the comment section changed to everyone vibing with them.
Everybody was just like, god, I wish...
I wish I could feel the joy they felt back then.
Right?
This is their soul.
They didn't know when the moment they went became adults.
Their soul was gone.
Hey, would you type in CyberGoth party?
CyberGoth dance.
Uh...
Reunion?
I don't know.
I don't remember.
I saw like a video of it, but I don't know.
I don't know where I found it.
What was CyberGoth?
CyberGoth dance reunion.
I like how there's like a video of it that pops up called Gothrave at a funeral.
Oh, there it is!
There it is!
I found it!
I'm gonna link it.
Oh, you found it?
Yo, yo, send it, send it, send it.
I'm gonna link it in my chat first and then I'll send it over.
Alright, bet.
Alright, I need to make sure I can send it.
Guys, it's not the same.
You can tell.
One of them is literally wearing a suit.
It's not... It's not the same.
What is this, like a 10 year reunion?
Oh my god, it's like 12 years later.
That's crazy.
This guy, one of them just came back from work and he's like, alright, don't worry.
I'll be here.
There's some very interesting results.
I love seeing all these different things I'm like going through right now.
That was 10 years ago.
12 years ago!
You can see it's not the same.
It was before they got real jobs!
Before they became adults!
I never foresaw this ending.
That guy in the fishnet shirt though, holy shit.
I'm pulling up your stream.
I gotta see it on your side.
No, I'm not even looking.
I'm not looking on stream.
I'm just looking.
This is on my other tab.
They changed that.
Reality hit them hard.
And they became businessmen.
They had to earn money.
They had to make money.
And pay taxes.
Wait, this is them?
Yeah, that's them.
It's the reunion.
They were sore for days after that.
Yo, this is what's gonna give us power for the next game.
Exactly, right here.
We're gonna bring back Cyber Goth.
What?
We're bringing it back.
Look at her.
What?
Oh my god, the main one at the front is the guy who was at the front of the other video.
I think they were placed in the same spot, right?
Yeah.
That's so crazy.
We're bringing it back.
We gotta sync it up.
A buddy in my chat said they're basically Fortnite skins.
They're basically Fortnite skins.
Wait, we gotta sync the dance.
You guys ready to emote together?
Yo, yo, we sync it?
Okay, wait.
Wait.
3, 2, 1, go.
No!
I just defeated it!
We got this, we got this.
3, 2, 1, go.
No, we're so close!
We're so close!
Okay, 3, 2, 1, go.
Yes!
Let's fucking go!
Oh my god!
We looked so good!
We even synced on my end.
As long as it synced on someone's side, that's all that matters.
It's like two in the frame.
It's actually like perfect.
We're gonna bring back Cyber God with Dragon Ball Z!
Yeah, this is the revival here.
The revival is coming.
It's happening.
I think it's great that we used Dragon Ball Z skins for Cyber God.
I also just love that you're running like Baby Bender on your back.
You have adult Yoda and I have Baby Bender.
Wait, what other ones do you have?
Let me see if I have like...
I wish you had like Baby Yoda.
Oh my god, why does he look like that?
Is this like...
Yoda looks so fucking off.
I know, right?
He looks like a Korean old man.
He's literally Star Wars.
He's literally an old man.
He's just an old man on my back.
It's like Goku...
You're Luke Skywalker, but Goku.
Are you playing with pretty graphics on your game?
I'm playing on medium.
Oh, you're playing... I'm so jealous.
I play on like ugly sweaty graphics.
So everything doesn't look as nice.
Let me do it again.
I know my play so I can play medium.
There's no point in putting it on low.
I know there's...
I know there's no point in putting it on low.
I'm literally gonna get shit on no matter what.
Your new model looks so good.
My new skin suit.
Look at how your new skin suit looks.
That's so good.
Oh, we're starting.
We're starting.
Are we going in?
Hey guys, is the volume a lot better now, chat?
By the way, my usual sound guy, he's at Evo right now.
So...
What game is he playing at Evo?
I don't know.
That's why he's like, oh sorry, I can't do sound check.
Look at my Yoda.
Oh my god.
Get rid of that crown.
Yeah, I got rid of it.
I got rid of it.
Okay, you remember our Josh Plot, yeah?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're pretty far from it.
We got some time.
We're chillin'.
Look at this battle bus.
We're literally vibing.
Okay, don't worry.
I'm gonna adjust the sound now, guys.
Sound effects.
Music.
That should be better now.
Alright, drop now.
Just in time.
Yay!
Maybe you'll land a little short, too.
We have all this side, so we should be okay.
I'm gonna land right here, but you should pop your parachute now.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
My parachute is the dragon.
Oh, you're using the dragon?
I'm using fucking Nike kicks.
What?
Why?
I see the fucking shoes.
I am playing on 60 frames.
Why am I on 60 frames?
Oh, it doesn't matter.
Oh my god, Yoda is laughing.
It is weirding me out right now.
Alright, let's see.
I'm grabbing the guns.
Oh my god, it's so weird seeing, like, all these footstep icons.
Yoda is really, really creeping me out.
Yoda's creeping you out just looking at him, staring at you.
No, he makes sounds.
He goes like Wait, does he actually?
Yeah.
That's looking weird.
Yoda, that's fucking cringe.
Yoda, you got something cringey.
Yeah, don't be cringe, Yoda.
We're trying to play a tournament right now.
I'm thinking of our croissant.
Yeah, wait, there's a little crash thingy.
There's a plunger gun here.
Oh, that gun is so nasty.
No, you should use it.
No, it's hitscan.
It's so good.
That's a plunger gun.
Oh, the gun that you pinged?
Oh, that one.
Okay.
The one next to it?
The one next to it is nasty, though.
It's so good.
Oh, there's a gun next to it?
Yeah.
That gun is so good.
Wait, I'll give it to you.
No, you should use it.
You know how to use this.
There's that?
Yeah, you use it.
I'll get the grab there.
No, I don't know what the fuck I'm doing.
I don't know.
I mean, I kinda know what I'm doing.
You don't even know what this gun is.
I was like, what the fuck is this gun?
Alright, here, I'm gonna splash this in.
Actually, no, you pop that big pot.
Pop the big pot.
And then I'm gonna finish doing this.
What is this gun?
I'm drinking.
I'm sipping my thing.
Oh, we're in zone.
That's good.
Oh my god, we're hella in zone, too.
We're chillin'.
How was I locked in 60?
What the fuck?
I didn't even realize.
Were you locked in 60 FPS?
Yeah, I was locked in 60.
I swear I, like, changed it.
I wonder if the settings actually reset for you.
I wasn't sure if it would, like, do it or not.
No, it, like, half reset.
So, like, I had to fix some of the stuff, but, like, I remember changing it past 60.
Oh my god.
We're so much more fluid now.
Okay, you see this shield bubble?
Yeah.
That is pink?
Okay, like, did you ever play Halo back then?
Oh, actually, no.
Better yet, this is like a fucking Gibby bubble.
You literally throw it at your feet and it basically protects you.
Okay, that's good.
I think it's like 10 seconds.
There's another one there.
What gun is this?
Is that a rifle?
Yeah, they're all hitscan, too.
Okay, that's good.
I have all jumping stuff.
Wait, we have to move again.
Oh, we have to go past Dusty.
Okay, so we can go over here.
We're gonna go towards the condo.
Whoa, we gotta do this.
Nice.
Yeah, we gotta do it for good luck.
Where is it?
Where's my...
We're doing it for good luck, guys.
We need this.
We are also not the last team again, by the way.
Okay, nice.
We're not last.
We are not dead last.
Alright, let's go...
Yeah, I guess go down here.
I don't even have a shotgun.
This is terrible.
Oh, no.
It's okay.
We're not last.
Just be thankful.
Let's see.
Is there...
Oh, we got movement.
Okay, sweet.
So, I have these jumpy pads that are... Yeah.
I have jump pads, too.
Oh, yeah, those, too.
Oh, in front of us?
I'm gonna back up real quick.
Whoa.
I'm gonna do this.
Pause on this.
Oh, God.
Wait, I got knocked already?
Oh, actually, I'm gonna bleed out.
Run away from me.
Run away.
Use the jumpy pad.
What the fuck?
No!
I'm saving it!
The condom skins!
No!
I got shot before I could even see them.
Like, I was literally out of LOS, and I literally died because of ping around the corner.
Oh, no!
It's because they land next to us, so their condom men are always gonna be there.
Okay, now that I know they're gonna do that, I'm gonna literally play hyper-aggressive.
Like, I am confident I can definitely kill one of them.
I believe.
I believe in you.
Alright, don't worry.
Now we can talk strategy.
So, the strat is gonna be that we literally kill these guys.
That is the strat.
Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, we gotta swap.
We didn't get a chance to use more of Dragon Ball Z, so we gotta keep going.
We gotta swap Dragon Ball Z characters.
Goku and Frieza just were not it.
They were not it.
They were raving a little too hard, but not hard enough.
Yeah, yeah, we gotta do different Dragon Ball Z characters.
I have Cell and you have Vegeta, right?
Yeah, I have Vegeta.
We'll go Vegeta and Cell.
They're better than Goku and Frieza.
So, seeing how this team is playing though, I think usually what ends up happening, it's kinda like how Apex is, where once you get a feel for the team that lands next to your POI, they'll basically play off of that.
And this team knows that we're being very evasive.
So, what we'll do is that we'll be ready for whatever angles they're gonna hold, and we'll just play counter-aggressive on them.
And if the zone ends up pulling where we have to run past them again, we can do a thing where we go towards the Loot Lake house on the island, and then we can rotate from there.
They're probably gonna either look for us from where we usually rotate, or they're just gonna not even mind us and deal with the team to the right.
And I think that'll be the plan.
I think that'll be the plan.
I have no idea what you said, but I agree.
I'll just follow you.
Just nod your head and say yes.
And then we'll be like, yeah, yeah, yeah, we're good, we're good.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
From everything I heard from what you said, I just need to follow you.
Okay, I got that.
I understand.
I think what I should've probably did, though, too, is just been like, oh, just give me bubble me if I go down.
Oh, that's true.
That's on me.
I didn't even say any of that.
No, I'm pretty sure they would've killed us because they were there so fast.
They also had shockwaves ready for the moment they got a knock.
We just got unlucky on our way.
Sweats, condom men.
What are these guys doing?
It could be anything else, and you chose condom men.
Look at this team on top of the hill.
They're probably some very colorful Fortnite skins, and these guys are like, yeah, we're gonna eat a condom.
Fortnite made billions of dollars off of skin cells, and you decide to be condoms?
Condoms are, I guess, the new thing.
They're not even a good skin.
They look so ugly.
Say it louder for the people in the back.
Is it because it's hard to see them?
I don't understand.
What's the appeal?
It's pretty much that.
If you're playing on ultra-pretty graphics, it's harder to see them.
Also, it's a very minimal slim hitbox skin.
Wait, it affects the hitbox?
I think it's like four different hitbox sizes in the game.
Wait, this is sweaty wraith skin.
The reason why people play the bald wraith is because of the smaller hitbox.
Yup, yup.
It's very much that.
This is a fucking scam!
It's pay to win!
Oh, these guys are gonna fight?
What the fuck is this tree?
Wait, you can grow a tree?
What?
Wait, what?
Why are they growing a tree?
Condoms vs condoms!
What?
Who the fuck?
You can grow trees?
Is this Mr. Beast?
Yo, what?
Mr. Beast growing trees?
Yeah, is this Mr. Beast growing the trees?
They have the Mr. Beast skin, right?
Yeah!
Wait, did you see what happened to them?
You saw how they got jumped?
It's like what we almost did to them last game.
Oh, they're probably gonna die here!
They might die here.
Oh, no.
Wait, they're resetting?
Okay, so, you know how you respawn?
As long as one person's alive?
Yeah.
No, what I did was you can choose to bleed out very fast.
So that way it respawns you faster.
Oh!
So if you feel like it's just gonna be like a sucky situation, you can just like say, alright, I'm out, bye, and then just respawn.
But like, I have to live long enough.
Yeah, yeah.
What the fuck?
How do you keep growing trees?
Why are they still planting?
Because they're Mr. Beast and it's a condom.
What was that Mr. Beast growing trees thing that he did?
Yeah, that was like, I planted a bajillion trees in like some country or whatever.
Yeah, yeah.
What was it called again?
They're Team Trees!
They're fucking Team Trees!
Yo, Team Trees?
Oh my god, I'm gonna burn some plastic to counteract this.
If you can plant trees in Fortnite, you should be able to burn plastic.
Oh my god.
Yo, yo.
Keep burning plastic out of here.
It should be like the nerf to the tree thing.
In game, guys.
It's all in game.
Aaron's like, why would you do that, Dopey?
Like, if these guys are gonna plant trees, we just wanna burn the plastic in the game.
Yeah!
Burn the plastic to counteract all the trees that they're planting!
It's crazy.
For anyone wondering, hitboxing is a myth?
Oh no, that's true.
That's true.
Cause like, I think there's like three or four body types in Fortnite.
I don't think it actually changes the hitbox.
Oh yeah, cause Peter Griffin has a different Peter Griffin's definitely not the same hitbox as this.
Yeah, he's like There's no way.
Gigantic.
Wait, do you have the chicken?
I do have the chicken, I have the chicken.
You have the chicken?
I have Peter!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yo, we could do the chicken and Peter.
Oh my god, we could do the chicken and the chicken!
Okay, we gotta do it on like game four or something like that.
Unless we wanna do it next game.
No, no, no.
We'll do Peter and the chicken next game, and then game four, we'll bring back Dragon Ball.
Alright, I'm down.
I'm down.
Someone's like, they're playing wide hitbox, they want to lose.
Oh, what do you mean that?
That's like the Giga Chat move.
Everyone's gonna respect that.
They're gonna be like, oh, I do not wanna mess with the chicken and Peter Griffin.
They see our skins and they're just like, oh, they definitely don't know what they're doing.
We can definitely farm them.
Oh my god, I love how like, where nearly everyone is with their jumps.
Holy shit, these guys are sweat.
No wonder my three Fortnite pro players fucking dodged me.
Wait, they're all condom skins!
Jesus!
It's 500!
Oh my god!
They're all condom skins.
I love how like, Fortnite compared to Apex is like the strat still 1v1 fight is running in circles to get a right hand peek on someone.
That's literally Fortnite.
Yeah.
Oh, I got it.
Are we the only one that's not running the skin?
Everyone's running some like, condom skin and we're just like very, very colorful chickens.
They definitely know where to find us.
That's for sure.
These look like NPCs fighting.
They do.
They naturally do.
They look like NPCs.
They say, I don't wanna be the main character.
I'm just gonna be I'm gonna be an NPC.
Oh my god.
Oh, reboots are disabled now.
Another condom?
Yeah, we're playing an attorney so everyone I think wants to be a condom.
Yeah, everybody wants to be the condom players.
What the fuck?
There she is, one of them.
Please show me somebody that's not a condom.
Yeah, I'm gonna actually cycle through all the players.
Oh, I got someone who's not a condom.
Wait, who, who?
Who is this?
Oh my god, this guy!
Jade?
Wait, they're all they're all like, they have same skin.
Ew, there's another green condom.
Why are they all growing trees?
Oh, these are the like OG sweat skins.
Oh wait, there's more.
Wait, can I cycle through the next one?
Is this like a fucking skill?
Why do some of them have trees growing?
Or are they hiding in a tree?
Oh, these ones have like cat ears.
Let's see.
Oh hey!
This is green condom.
This one has green condom.
Whoa, these chicks are from the witcher.
I think.
Okay, so there's like witcher skins, and then there's some like cat ear skins that I can't find.
Oh my god, they're all the same skin!
Fucking beta male shit!
Why could you do fiend?
Be more fun!
Oh, a condom's dead!
Okay, same skin?
That's so like, that's so like 2002.
Whatever happened to not being a condom?
I remember back in the good old days when no one wanted to be a condom.
This is lazy.
Lazy, lazy teamwork.
They're growing trees again.
I'm gonna literally use that call out now because of you.
You're like, I'm growing trees?
I'm growing trees?
I'm growing trees.
Where's the individuality?
This is what like, the other players that bailed on you missed out on, is like new call out that no one else is gonna know.
Exactly.
You're just inventing new slang.
I swear, it's not fair, like why can't I burn plastic in Fortnite if I can grow trees?
Like, we should, it should be perfectly balanced.
Wait, what?
Oh, okay, it's the witcher skins again.
Oh, nice.
Okay.
I respect this team.
Who is this?
Oh, they're all anonymous.
What the fuck?
I think these are witcher skins.
Are these guys from witcher?
All of them are same skin!
None of them are like they're all actually same skin!
Holy shit!
Everybody that's alive is wearing the same thing.
So boring.
This is why Fortnite is competitive instead.
I've been asked so many times, like, why don't I play competitive in this game?
I'm like, I like playing this game in a very, very dumb manner.
I like it for all the the giant toonie chicken skins.
Yeah!
And I like WP.
You play Fortnite competitive, all you see are these dumb, dumb condom skins in different colors.
Then there's also, like, this is zero build, but everyone still builds ramps.
Cause there's fucking they should, they should be able to remove items like Smash Brothers.
That's what I've always said, I'm just like, yo, remove that shit.
Like, you know how, like, in competitive Apex, they remove like, all the, uh, what is it called?
The...
the heat shields?
Yeah!
The heat shields are removed?
Yeah.
But Portabunga should be removed!
I'm pretty sure they are modifiable, but, like, I think they just leave them because they want it to be, like, how it is in the regular mode?
I don't even know.
Yeah!
They couldn't... Fortnite could can have even more... Fortnite competitive can have more sponsors.
And they force all of them to wear, like, funny skins.
No, I would do that tournament in a heartbeat.
They're like, no, no sweat skins, no matching skins.
You have to be all different.
Yeah, everybody...
You know how, like, you gotta claim your drop spot?
You gotta claim your skin.
Yeah, yeah.
Each person has to have a different skin, so you gotta claim whichever skin you're wearing, so...
Yo... Yo, I'm... Okay, I think you're cooking right now.
People wanna watch Fortnite rake more.
I think you're actually cooking.
You're cooking something, Doki.
Is this the next tournament that's gonna happen?
Like, I would actually do a tournament like that.
That would be so fucking fun.
That's like, literally free advertisement with, like, for the other pieces... Like, imagine, like, the person wearing the weekend skin won, like, a million dollar Fortnite bucks.
Like, and then, like, you know, the weekend get, like, free advertisement.
And then, like...
And then people will be like, well, I want to wear the weekend skin!
And then people will...
And then all the little kitties are gonna buy the weekend skin even more!
Yo... Okay, okay, no, no, no.
On the real?
Okay, I'm, like, I'm even thinking, what if you do that and, like, you force everyone to not use any of these items, right?
Like, it's all, like, just movement items.
All, like, things that just add more chaos to the mix.
That would be so stupid fun.
Yeah!
Exactly!
That would be so fun.
Just, you know, just remove all items in general.
Just...
The thing is, the reason why they need this is because Fortnite is such an open map in general.
They don't have enough cover.
Unlike Apex or...
Unlike Apex and other FPS games, maps are designed to have cover.
Fortnite is designed to not have cover because they expect you to make your cover.
Yeah, so 0-bill players just go through it.
They need to have the bunker, yeah.
They need the bunkers.
Look at this nerd, he downed himself.
Oh!
Condom dead!
A non-condom team won!
Yeah, but they have the same skin, don't they?
Are they wearing the same skin together?
I think they are, yeah.
No!
It's okay.
As long as there's no condom winners, we all win.
They go against the meta!
That's all that matters.
Okay, I put Peter Griffin on.
Alright, I'm putting the chicken on.
It's time to be a chicken.
Let's see what dance...
Is there any cool dances on the store?
Oh, let me change...
It's time to shop.
My emotes.
Wait, do you have Batman later?
Uhhh...
Do you have Batman?
The skin?
Or like the emotes?
No, I don't have Batman.
No, because I have the Batman who laughs.
Oh, that's getting sick.
Wait, I have Mr. Beast!
Oh, I bought Mr. Beast!
Oh my god!
I forgot it was in the store!
I was like, I gotta have Mr. Beast.
Oh my god.
Wait, if we find the trees, I wanna be Mr. Beast and plant the trees.
I don't care if we die, I just wanna plant some trees.
Okay, one of these rounds, we have to do Mr. Beast and someone else.
Who would I be?
Who would you be?
Chat, who would match with Mr. Beast?
Who would match with Mr. Beast, guys?
Let's see, let's see.
Go, Peter, go!
I'm like watching him dance right now.
Neo?
Is there another YouTuber?
Is there another YouTuber skin that you have?
Let me see, let me see.
There is...
Oh, I guess I could be like Caby Lane.
The guy who does the shrug?
You know, he's really big on TikTok.
He does the shrugging all the time.
Wait, wait, wait, okay.
Oh my god, Peter!
Oh my, I'm looking at like the different emotes.
Like the emotes that I could get.
What the fuck?
Oh my god, wait, I need to buy this.
Give me a sec, I'm gonna hide my screen.
Yeah, yeah, you're good, you're good, you're good.
Guys, I need to buy this, guys.
I need...
I have to buy this.
Okay, I'm gonna equip.
Nice!
Okay.
What's this?
Oh my god, he's fucking shredding it!
Oh my god!
I have so many!
I have so many anime skins.
Okay, wait, wait, show me the other YouTuber.
The other YouTuber?
Dang, he's partially on YouTube.
He's like more TikTok, but...
This guy.
Oh, wasn't he banned on YouTube?
Yeah.
Wait, did he get banned on YouTube?
I don't remember, I remember he got banned somewhere.
Or was it Twitter?
Oh, I know, I know!
Wait, how the fuck did he get a...
How did he get a Fortnite skin?
I don't know, I'm just a wolf.
Bro, somebody...
Bro, somebody must really...
Somebody at Fortnite must really, really like this guy!
Just don't expect him to get a Fortnite skin.
Wait, what other guys do they have?
Let's see, do I have another YouTuber?
Oh, I'm going through all these.
Um...
Alright, wait.
I don't know if I have another...
I mean, I might have like a gamer YouTuber, but...
I don't have like...
I'm like Mr. Beast.
Look who I got.
Wait, who you got, who you got?
Look who I bought.
Look at him go!
Yo, I have the emote!
Oh, do you get the new code?
Oh, we just got a new code, hold on.
Okay.
Bam, bam, bam, bam, bam!
Did you guys hear that chat?
Fortnite killer!
Oh yeah, I should...
No one is ready.
I should change some of my emotes too.
Uh...
Emotes, okay, what do I...
I want to keep the Macarena.
Oh, Christmas tree skin for Mr. Beast.
Oh, that's true!
You should be a tree!
Yeah, I can be a tree.
I have a Christmas tree.
Okay, I need...
Where's the...
What's that emote called again?
Which one?
The one you were just doing.
Oh, Master Puppets, okay.
Yeah, it should be at the top.
Wait, where's the...
Where's the fucking... Oh, there it is.
Okay, I got it, I got it.
I gotta make sure this is in there.
You have it?
Okay, let's go.
Look at the guitar!
It's like out of his skin.
His body is so fucking massive.
It's so fucking big.
Oh my god.
I'm winning in spirit.
Look at his, like, giant toonie eyes.
What the fuck?
How many emotes do you have?
I have way too many.
You don't even wanna know all that I have.
Oh wait, that's the witcher!
Which one?
This one?
No, the bathtub.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Is that the witcher?
Oh, is that from the witcher?
Did he take a bath?
Yeah, he takes a bath in that thing.
Yeah.
I had no idea.
Oh my god, I feel so concerned.
I thought that was the witcher.
This is... I have a little truck.
Yay, beep beep.
Beep beep.
Oh my god, it clipped in the chair!
I think you're gonna die first.
But I will never die.
Look at how tiny the hitbox is.
Holy shit, you have so... wait, how do you, like, scroll through more?
Oh, there's more pages!
Yeah, I got the classic.
I have way too many pages.
Oh my god, I got the classic.
Oh, wait, I have the new run too.
Guilty as sweet.
Okay, not that.
What is that?
That's an attack on Titan emote.
It's the AoT one.
Wait, what's the other one?
What's that?
It looks so terrifying, it's a silly bird.
Oh my god.
These all look so crazy.
Can you have Futurama?
What the fuck is that?
What is that?
I think it's, uh, DC?
It's a DC collab.
Oh, it's from one of the DC comics.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
I have Dead Space.
What the fuck?
What is up?
And the classic Fortnite.
Yo, the classic one, we gotta do the classic.
Wait, where do I have that one?
Oh, hey, Gumi!
Yeah, I just love Fortnite emotes.
Oh, wait, I have this.
Wait, no, I have this.
Wait, where the fuck did I get this?
Oh, Black Adam, that's what it is.
Is that Kung Fu Panda?
Oh my god, I get to look at Kung Fu Panda.
I think it's supposed to be, um...
There's like a Master Sifu skin or something.
Nuh-uh.
They have so many things in this game.
That's why I'm like, I can't get this game serious.
Wait, did we get it?
Did we get it?
Did we get missed?
Uh...
Wait...
Oh, no, no, we're good, we're good, we're good.
I couldn't help it.
Cool emotes!
Look at these!
Oh, we just made it!
We just made it!
They're like, we're missing one duo.
We're missing one duo.
Who could it be?
Not me!
Emo with you, emo with you.
Yeah!
Yeah, join us!
Why is this going?
No!
It's not even Christmas, lady!
Okay, tell me when to drop.
Alright, alright, uh...
We're...
good about...
now.
Alright, guys, I increased the game volume more.
I hope the volume's better now.
We're so locked in, guys.
We're locked in.
No one even knows how locked in we are.
Yeah, we're so locked in.
Yay!
This is the skin that will make us be like, we haven't been last yet, guys!
We're so locked in!
There's another team that is losing before us.
Yeah, exactly, and it's not us.
Oh, I got a shotgun?
Alright, we good?
We good?
Nice.
I'm drinking some...
I'm about to be done?
Looting me?
Drinking some stuff.
Oh, the chest has space now!
That's cool.
There's a llama over here!
Oh, it's so risky for me to go for that.
Okay, I'm gonna go to you.
Oh, I got the same thing.
Wait, J3?
We're doing better than J3?
That's right, that's what you get for having two Overwatch players.
Oh, is that an Overwatch player?
Yeah, they're both Overwatch players.
Oh, I did not know that.
That team is literally an Overwatch team.
That's what you get.
Do we get counted as Apex players?
I don't know.
I don't know what they count me as.
They count me as the person from YouTube that they're bringing over.
I'm just the trusty sidekick.
The V2 werewolf.
The chicken.
You're the Fortnite bodyguard.
To make sure I don't die first.
You gotta make sure you're not last, that's it.
I'm the exchange student, yeah.
I'm the exchange student.
What is this?
What gun is this?
Oh, it's an infantry rifle.
Which is...
actually really, really good.
I have one, too.
And then you can splash us one more time.
Yay!
We're good, we're good.
Now that we're kind of on zone, we can watch out for this team.
Or we can just keep rotating north.
We can go over here.
It's your pick.
I know what I'm doing.
Let's rotate right now.
Okay.
I'm gonna go down on the...
It's kind of a scary rotate because we kind of have to go out in the open.
Yeah.
It is pretty scary.
Do you have any protection at all?
Before we get pushed?
I have the shockwave grenade.
Oh, you have the shockwave.
You saw how it works, right?
Okay, I'm gonna give you my shockwave grenades.
No, you don't want them?
I don't think I can do the things they were doing.
Okay, we can literally chill inside here.
Or we can keep on moving towards...
Wait, can we...
Let's see.
Oh my god.
We can't go into the bathroom?
We can't hide in the bathroom?
What we could do is we could chill here and wait.
So we're gonna have to keep on rotating.
We can keep going this way.
So I'm gonna go outside.
Keep on following me.
I'm following.
Okay.
Did anyone die yet, guys?
Nobody's dead yet?
One team has died.
One team died.
We're not dead last time.
That's great.
That's what I like to hear.
Oh my god.
The Overwatch player is dying.
Yeah!
Oh my god.
That's great.
It's great to know.
We can hide here in the bush.
Oh my god.
We can be Bushmen too.
Wait, they probably know.
I'm gonna move to the left.
Oh my god.
We can be Bushmen too.
Can I get an angle?
Yeah, they're on rooftop.
They know.
They are at...
Looping?
Okay.
Are they looking at us?
They know that we're here.
They're rotating.
Okay.
Oh my god.
I can see the...
Almost cracked one.
Oh my god.
They're planting trees again!
Let's go left.
How do I keep getting the trees?
I'm gonna get you on the side.
I'm good though.
Oh, I'm not.
I'm gonna do this.
I'm doing this.
I'm not good.
We're good.
We can go inside here.
Oh, nice.
Nice.
Yeah, just watch yourself.
And then...
Let's see.
Let me actually get an angle to try and shoot them.
They're still on the rooftop.
Okay.
We can keep moving to the next house over.
So, let's go outside here.
And I'm gonna start rotating.
We are safe for now.
Oh my god.
Inside.
These minis here are huge.
I feel safer inside.
I think we can move over to the next house.
I'm going to...
Should I break the wall?
Okay, we're gonna go out the back door like we did the last house.
Okay.
Let's go now.
Thank you, Fortnite bodyguard.
You're welcome, other Fortnite bodyguard.
Alright, we're chillin'.
We're chillin' here.
We're good.
Protect me, Fortnite bodyguard.
Alright, we get to just hang out here until the next...
Oh, they're in the bush.
Oh, they're bush people.
How can you be a bush person if you're not Mr. Beast?
I know, right?
These guys are.
How could you?
Oh, wait.
Okay.
I don't know if there's anyone below us.
Oh, wait.
Okay.
I don't know if there's anyone below us.
There's footsteps.
I'm gonna actually just move around.
I'm gonna make noise.
They're on the other house.
Get away!
This is our house!
They could shoot you in the back.
Okay.
But they're...
I hear you.
Yeah, I hear them.
I think they might want to fight.
See them on the rooftop.
I'm below.
They should get shot on the top.
What are you doing?
I have my shotgun too!
Okay, so you know how the shockwaves work, kind of.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
If they can't push you guys, don't feel bad to shockwave yourself.
Carelessly.
Okay.
If you shockwave me into the storm, that's okay.
Because I can shockwave myself another direction.
Okay.
So, just play selfishly if they end up trying to push us.
They're waiting for an opportunity to jump us.
So, I'm just watching around.
Yeah, that's right.
I have my bodyguard here.
It's a fucking dog.
I could break their rooftop?
Okay.
Oh, wait.
They got shot at.
Are they?
Wait, no.
They fell.
Wait, are they...
They might be rotating.
I think they're rotating.
Yeah, they're rotating.
We're good.
Okay, so...
We're gonna have to rotate...
Let me see what's available.
I think... Is that in?
Alright, so we're gonna go out the back again.
And we're gonna... Okay, I want you to slide run onto...
Oh, team on our side.
On the right side.
I see them.
Almost cracked them.
Almost cracked the other two.
We're gonna shockwave to the other house over here.
Okay.
So, just...
Get away from me.
And then I'm gonna shockwave.
I'm going now.
And then I'm going to...
Launch pad.
And go this way.
I'm looking for you.
You're good!
You're good, Toki.
I'm looking for you.
I'm over here.
You're good.
Yo, you're good!
I did it!
Yo, we're good!
We're so good!
Okay, we're in next zone.
We're in next zone.
We're chillin'.
Oh my god!
We're doing it!
We're doing that movement!
There's a Gibby bubble right here as well.
Okay, yeah, yeah.
I can take it.
Oh, we're also in next zone, too.
We're in next zone, too.
We're chillin'.
Oh, thank god.
I'm gonna be hiding in the bunker.
The fallout's coming.
I'm gonna hide in the bunker.
I think we forced that team to rotate onto another team.
So, we're good.
We're good for now.
Okay, I'll stay here.
I think... I'm gonna get onto...
Someone kill the Overwatch squad already, so at least I can be better than the Overwatch people.
That's all I want.
I cracked one in Storm, but they're eating a lot of damage over here, so...
I'm gonna keep pressure on them.
I think I'm actually okay up here.
I'm worried.
We have this whole house.
I'm so scared of peeking, though.
Yeah, no, you can chill inside.
Okay, I'm looking into... I'm looking here.
Are you still in zone?
Yeah, we're still in zone.
There's gonna be one over here.
They're shooting.
Are they still in zone?
Yeah, they're still, like, out of the...
in the blue right now.
I think they rotated to the water side.
Are you getting shot at?
No, do you hear that?
That was an RPG.
Oh, what?
They're shooting RPGs at us.
It was like...
I was like, what the fuck was that?
Okay, I think this guy went over here?
Oh, thank God the Overwatch duo is dead.
We're vibing right now.
We're not vibing as much anymore.
We are not.
That is so far.
We have the beast that we can play on.
What the fuck?
Let's see.
What can we actually play here?
I'm gonna kinda look out for a spot that we can get to.
Is that in?
Oh, that is very in.
Okay, we can get to that rock there, I think.
We can get to that rock there, I think.
I have another shock if you want one.
How many do you have?
Oh, you do?
No, keep it for yourself because I have launch pads.
We're gonna go with the zone very very last second.
You know how the crash pads work?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, just slide crouch onto it.
I'm gonna burn some right now.
Okay, we're gonna try to get to my blue thing.
Let me go now.
We're gonna go here.
I'm gonna chill here for a sec.
Oh, what's in here?
What's in here?
Did I get shot?
Okay, no.
No, we're good, we're good, we're good.
We're gonna do a slow rotate.
Okay.
We're gonna be little babies.
Is that team on the port-a-pot?
Port-a-bunker right there?
Oh!
No, no, no!
You're good, you're good, you're good.
I don't feel good.
I might be dead.
They're like in the ocean.
I was so confused.
They're over there, they're over there.
Wait, can I reboot?
Oh, I might be dead.
No, don't die!
I can reboot!
No!
I might have been able to res you.
Oh, you're still alive?
No, I died, I died, I died.
No!
I was so confused.
I was like, what was that?
What's shooting me?
We're like in the...
He's hiding in the fucking bush!
What expects them to be in the water?
Yup, Fortnite moment, Fortnite moment.
No!
It's okay, we did better.
Yeah, we did better.
We did not die in dead last.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We were 15?
Yeah, and we didn't die to the condom people.
I died to the condom on height, but you didn't die to the...
I died to the water people.
At least one of us is better, I guess.
No, I died to a condom.
You died to a condom person.
I can't believe it.
What the fuck, what the fuck is going on here?
We actually did really, really good there, though.
Like, look, we got our synergy down.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, we're getting better and better, getting better placements.
Yeah.
Yeah, from, we got 15th, 16th, and like, we don't talk about the other one, but 15th and 16th.
That's pretty good.
That's really good.
That's really, really good.
I'm proud of us.
Against all these other Fortnite people, and our gamers, that's pretty.
And no matter what, we win money.
So like, no matter how well we...
No matter how well we do, everybody wins money.
Holy shit.
Oh my god.
How many bunkers is this one?
Is the entire loot just bunkers?
Okay, so like, I've been playing Reloaded with a bunch of friends lately.
Yeah.
And my biggest complaint is literally the fact that bunkers exist.
Because it turns into this, but in like, casual too.
But like, it feels like they have like 20 houses.
I know, right?
Yeah.
When you play quads, it's literally like fortresses that you're going against.
Like, how many houses can you carry?
Um, it's uh, four per stack.
You can carry four houses?
Yeah, you can carry four of them.
And this guy must have like eight or some shit.
There's no fucking way.
I literally I literally saw him build like four different houses.
And he still had houses.
He still has bunkers!
He still has another bunker?
This guy doesn't realize that he's gonna break his bush.
He broke his bush!
No!
How does he still have a house?
No, your reactions are filling me with life, because that is... What?
All of my reactions when I first started playing Fortnite, and it still is the same.
What the fuck is like the real estate market in Fortnite?
How many...
They're gonna burst a bubble?
How many houses does he have?
Wait, wait, which guy are you watching?
I'm watching this like, JF guy.
I don't know.
He's either JF or the Anonymous.
Oh, I'm expecting Anonymous 264, because this guy has like fucking Anonymous mode on.
But his team is like JF or something on Twitch.
Oh, JF!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, his teammate has like 200,000 houses.
Every time...
Every fucking time he gets like...
He wants to like advance or run away, he has a fucking house.
Oh, here we go.
Yeah, I'm watching JF right now.
You see all those houses around you?
He built all those houses.
He built this.
Maybe he's MrBeast.
Might actually be him.
Oh my god.
He's the MrBeast that builds houses!
Last game was the MrBeast that could plant trees.
This one fucking builds houses.
Oh?
Oh my god.
That's the RPG I heard.
Yeah, that was the RPG I heard.
Oh, it's the Christmas chicks.
Or the Christmas hats.
Oh my god.
Bro, does he have another house?
I swear to god.
If he throws another fucking house down, I swear... Okay, this is why us FPSers cannot main Fortnite.
The meta is literally you turn into a house.
That's the meta.
I swear to fucking god.
I swear it's so easy to plant houses too.
Oh my god, please someone kill him!
Oh, thank god.
He was ruining the economy.
Yes.
Oh my god, they're fully dead.
Thank god.
They died.
His teammate had a house that he was about to throw.
I saw him.
I saw him hold the fucking portal bunker.
He was like, I'm ready for it.
I'm going to grow a house again.
He had a bunker in his fucking head.
I'm not watching condom men.
I'm going to watch somebody else.
Wait, wait.
There's Christmas people in the house right now.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm watching the Christmas people.
Jesus Christ.
They're getting their house destroyed.
Oh my god.
It's okay.
They're fine.
They also built their own house.
Oh my god.
They built two houses.
Aww.
They built a duplex.
Yo, that's cute.
Oh my god.
The housing market is going crazy.
That's four houses.
That's four fucking portal bunkers.
He has a big one right there.
That's five.
Does he have another one?
No one can complain about not having a house anymore.
That's six.
Oh, there's seven.
Oh, and he goes down.
That's seven.
Don't worry.
Throw another one down.
Eight.
Nine.
This one team threw nine houses in 30 seconds.
I swear.
And he had another one.
I want a little ride.
Yo, you are my inner monologue.
I fucking love you so much.
He had ten houses in his hand.
He was gonna build ten houses in 30 seconds.
He built it for one.
In 30 seconds.
Oh my god.
Oh, you can hold four.
This man's entire inventory was literally just portal bunkers.
He had nothing else.
Oh my god.
Alright, these are the new comms.
I'm literally using Doki comms from now on.
I am not using any more of the comms that I've acquired throughout my time playing.
Did this guy even have guns?
I'm just gonna call it growing a house.
There's no way.
I think that guy I was watching had literally one gun and that's and the other four spots were portal bunkers.
Oh, the condom gibby bubbled.
He's doing a temporary house.
One stick of gun.
Okay, we built this city.
Oh, they're making boobs.
Have you ever seen...
They made boobs.
They saw it.
Look what they're doing again.
Oh, they're making houses again.
Yeah, yeah.
It's boobs and houses now.
That's the meta.
Oh, he blew the condom away.
Oh, shit.
That was actually a really good play.
He recycled them.
Yeah.
Oh, wait.
Wait.
Oh, he's gonna go house on me.
Oh, no.
He blew out.
Oh, that's so smart.
Oh, shit.
How many fucking... What?
Oh, his teammate's dead.
His teammate got too cocky.
Oh, my God.
You guys don't have to try this hard.
You're gonna be in day two anyway.
Oh, the condoms are dead.
No, it's a 1v1.
It's a 1v1.
He's dead.
Oh.
It's a 1v1.
Another condom.
Yeah.
Three games... Wait, what?
There's more?
Oh, I thought there was another team.
Chad's like, uh, do we need to show Doki the portal fortress?
Wait, when did... Oh, the Christmas... There's another Christmas team.
Wait, what?
Oh, my God.
There is more.
There was another team.
Oh, yeah.
Look.
There's, like, a white one and a red one.
Yeah, it's 1v2.
Oh, no.
Blue one, I mean.
It's 1v2 now.
Where the fuck did these guys third party?
I was like, where did these guys come from?
Oh?
Wait, what?
Where's the other team?
Are they just healing?
Is he just healing in the storm?
Oh, my God.
I like how it's still like a build mode heal off.
Oh, no.
He's yeah, he couldn't heal from that.
He's dead dead.
They won.
Oh, thank God.
I'm glad it's not.
Doki, the people's winner or the people's choice won.
We didn't have condoms win.
Oh, my God.
Thank God.
Two of the four games were not from the condoms.
That's all that matters.
The games were not completely cursed.
They were not cursed.
Yeah, yeah.
They were slightly, slightly cursed.
Wait, this is two out of three.
That's great.
That means, like, they tried so hard to be sweaty, but only one condom team won.
That's all I wanted.
Game number four?
Game four.
Yeah, yeah.
Are we going to do Mr. Beast or Dragon Ball Z?
Um, I'm down for Dragon Ball again.
Or do you want to do... No, let's switch it off.
Let's do Mr. Beast and...
Who did I say was going to be Capulet?
We're going to be Tree because we're going to play Tree.
Oh, yeah, Tree.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
All right, let's see.
And I'll have Mom's spaghetti on my backpack.
Wait, no, I should have, like, golf.
Because he's Mr. Beast.
I bet he loves golfing.
Oh, my God, but he could be the people's champion.
I'm going to be the Tree!
Wait, what is the Tree's name?
Christmas?
No?
Uh...
I know I have them here.
I could also be a big, giant corn.
Oh, I could have... Wait, I'm going to put... I'm going to put a piece of delivery in my backpack.
Oh, I love that one.
Maybe Mr. Beast delivering pizza.
I have an Amogus.
But I could also put a...
Actually, what would Mr. Beast put on the Christmas tree?
What would he put on the Christmas tree?
Do you have money?
Uh...
I might have money.
I think I have a money bag.
If you have money, we could put money in the back.
It would make sense!
We could use pom poms, too.
That's right.
Okay, a briefcase.
I think I have a briefcase.
A briefcase full of money.
Let's go.
We could be planting some trees.
Uh... I think that one might be okay.
Oh, is there one with money that's pouring out of it, chat?
Okay, that one's fine.
Okay.
We're using that.
And then...
Oh, what are you using for your pickaxe?
Oh, my pickaxe?
I'm using pom poms.
Oh, I have the pom poms, too!
Oh!
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Let's go find pom poms!
Alright, pom poms.
Mr. Beast is going to cheer us on.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're going to plant some trees, guys.
Today, we're going to be planting 100,000 trees.
Alright, what glider do I use?
I guess I'll just use...
Oh, no.
I have a money bag one.
I forgot.
It's actually money, like, flowing in the sky.
Oh, my God!
That's so good!
Wait!
That's perfect!
Yeah, do you have that one, too?
No, I don't.
But that's perfect.
Uh, I'll do...
the bananas?
Wait, I have bling!
Wait, is that bling?
No, are these rockets?
What is it?
Skyscratch.
What is that?
What the fuck is that?
Okay, I'll still use... Ooh, diamond!
Wait, when did you start playing the game?
I feel like we have a lot of the same Battle Pass stuff.
I have no idea.
I, like, play it on and off.
Like...
That was me this season.
When the season first started, I was like, oh, okay.
I'm definitely online in this car game.
40 streamers in the same Fortnite game.
Too real!
Wait, maybe if they have, like, do they have any money-related trails?
I have a staircase.
Ooh, go, Mr. Peace!
I can make it in the sky.
Mr. Peace, go!
Go support the trees, Mr. Peace!
And cure the blind!
You got this!
I'm gonna buy this, actually.
Like, oh, yeah, I'll do that.
I'll do that.
The money bag item is called, uh, Goldilocks.
Goldilocks.
No, I don't have it.
I bought a really good emote.
Awesome.
Guys, if you guys wanna support me so I can buy more more cosmetics in the future, use DokiBird and support a creator.
And then you keep that.
Use code DokiBird.
Use code DokiBird so we can buy more pretty cosmetics.
Alright, this is, I bought a new dance emote.
You wanna see?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, do it, do it, do it.
Okay, okay, okay.
Let's see, where is it?
Oh my god, where did I buy it?
I don't wanna- Did you just get it?
In the shop right now?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I just got it.
I wanna see if I can find it from, like, regular scrolling.
Is it glitter?
No!
Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah, I bought glitter.
Oh, I love that one!
Wait, did you just buy it?
No, I have that one in, uh, my inventory right now.
Okay, wait, wait.
I just gotta find it.
Yeah, I need to find glitter.
Wait, it's called glitter.
Alright, there it is.
Oh, Mr. Peace.
Okay.
Where is it?
Where's my main, main inventory for emotes?
Oh, there it is.
Go, Mr. Peace, go!
Plant those trees!
Show the world that you can be the next president of America!
You see this tree here?
I planted that!
I gave him life!
You see that?
I planted that tree!
I'm Mr. Peace!
Save the world!
Every day we get closer and closer.
And also, lock a hundred people into a supermarket battle royale style!
That's what they want!
We cured the blind!
I planted houses in Fortnite!
Yeah!
Oh, we got the new code.
Report?
Don't worry!
Let me throw money at you!
But first, you gotta do this grueling ten hour obstacle course if you wanna want that money, though!
And then I'm gonna give you V-Bucks!
And then you're gonna buy things in the video game using code Mr. Peace, and then I'm gonna cure you!
Oh yeah!
Alright, cool.
I'll get ready up.
Alright, I'll get ready up for real this time.
Wait, I'm gonna run the bathroom real quick.
I will BRB, cause I've been needing to pee.
Alright.
Maybe, like, after you pee, you'll get better, too.
I feel like that's gonna happen.
I'm gonna, like, exhaust all of my all my bad skills.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
The moment you pee, you'll become a better player.
It's happening.
Alright, BRB!
BRB chat!
Alright, see you later!
Guys, you guys think we're gonna do better?
Guys, every game we're getting a little bit better, you know?
As long as we're better than the Overwatch people, that's all that matters.
to me.
As long...
We're better than the Overwatch team.
That's all that matters.
And also, yeah, we can only go up from here.
And I bet you, we are the team that's having the most fun!
I bet you, nobody else is having just as much fun as we are, because that's all we have.
That's...
Like, we know our place in this tournament!
As long as we're having fun!
That's all that matters.
True.
If we don't have fun, what else can we do?
What else do we have?
We have six matches.
This is four.
So we have three more games.
Uh...
Where's the aimbot?
Guys, you know damn well that I'm not pulling up the aimbot iPhone.
I think I shot my gun like one time.
We've only shot our gun one time.
I know my place.
I'm just here to spend money on Fortnite and do silly dances.
That's what you need.
I'm here to dance!
Yes!
I landed one!
The one shot I landed?
The one shot...
Um... It hit.
That's all that mattered.
That's right.
Flex it, Mr. Beast.
Flex it!
Yeah, why shoot gun when everybody builds a fucking house?
We're out here trying to find houses to live in.
Everybody else is just building houses.
How do they find all those portabunkers?
That's what I'm confused about.
How does one drop spot have two hundred fucking portabunkers?
I don't understand.
When will I have my Fortnite skin?
Guys.
Guys, would you like want me to have... would you guys would you guys like spend at least a hundred thousand dollars on Fortnite if I have my skin on there?
Maybe...
Maybe that's how what it takes.
No.
Guys, this is exactly why I don't have a Fortnite skin.
I need commitment.
I need commitment here.
I mean maybe.
Guys, I need some commitment here.
I need to have a Fortnite skin.
Dude, I don't even give... Do they even... Okay.
How many like Fortnite players have they given skins to?
Okay.
Fortnite skins of Fortnite player.
Other than Ninja.
Is there like actual like Fortnite skins for actual like Fortnite... Okay.
Not like I'm saying like Ninja isn't a Fortnite player.
Quite a lot?
Wait.
Really?
Okay.
I'm looking.
They have Ninja.
They have Travis Scott.
I forgot about that.
All the time?
Oh, you're right!
I see Loserfruit there!
Wait, you're right!
Guys, I need you guys to spend a hundred thousand...
I'm gonna shoot Fortnite an email and be like...
I mean if like...
What's his name?
The...
Lame?
What's his name?
Like a guy that shrugs!
If he gets a Fortnite skin!
Oh, cause he has 81 million followers on Instagram.
That makes a lot more sense now.
Guys, that guy, this guy, who you're like...
He has 81 million followers.
He has a video with Will Smith?
Cause I don't have...
Okay, I'm back!
Welcome back, Dory!
Wait, wait, what are we talking about?
I heard Will Smith.
Let's talk about that YouTube skin you have.
The... what's his name?
Oh, Cappy Lame?
Yeah, Cappy Lame.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I was like, if he can have a Fortnite skin, I should have one.
But then I looked him up and he has 81 million followers on Instagram.
Oh my, what?
And I was like, oh, okay, that...
I was just like, oh!
That's why he has a... That is insane!
That's why!
I had no idea he had that much, like...
I didn't either!
That's crazy!
That's so cool!
People in my chat was like, who is that guy?
I was like, this guy did a...
This guy did a fucking video with Will Smith!
Like...
Where's my Will?
And they're like, where's your Will Smith collab?
I don't fucking know!
Yeah, wait, when are you collabing with Will Smith?
Will Smith answered my DMs!
Hahahaha!
That's gonna be such a wild collab if you ever play with him or Caby Lane.
You even think Caby Lane plays Fortnite?
Does he play Fortnite?
Wait, is that why he got Fortnite skin?
I don't know, I feel like... Do you think Eminem plays Fortnite?
Cause Eminem also has a skin too in the game.
Well, Eminem doesn't play Fortnite, he's just like there for, like, his music.
I mean, like, does he think Lady Gaga plays Fortnite?
I think Lady Gaga did play Fortnite.
Wait, Lady Gaga played Fortnite?
I think?
Wait, no, she has to have.
There's no way!
She has, like, three skins in the game.
She has three skins?
Lady Gaga has three!
Why does Lady Gaga need three skins in Fortnite?
Lady Gaga has, like, I think two variants, and then...
I think she might have, like, one that you can chain?
Like a different variant?
There's no way.
Wait, she fucking tweeted out about Fortnite!
Wait, two years ago, today, Lady Gaga kicked- oh wait, no, that's just somebody's, like, Lady Gaga Fortnite account.
I was like, oh my god, did Lady Gaga tweet about Fortnite?
But no.
She also has 170 million TikTok followers?
Oh, for Cavity?
Oh, what?
Yeah, I know about that.
Bro, Brandon Urie plays Fortnite?
He used to be a Twitch streamer.
Dang!
Like, I used- Oh, I made sure to hydrate.
Wait, did we- did I already up?
I did, okay.
Hey, we good, we good.
Okay, Fortnite skin.
Does Brandon Urie have- Brandon Urie doesn't even have Fortnite skin!
If anybody deserves a Fortnite skin, it's Brandon Urie.
Wait, who's Brandon Urie?
Brandon Urie, he did the- he did, like, the uh, uh, he's Panic at the Disco.
Oh, wait, what?
Yeah!
Oh shit!
Yeah, he streams Fortnite!
I've seen him stream Fortnite!
Dang.
I don't know if he still streams it.
See, there's, like, some singers who actually have, like, time in the game.
Yeah!
I know that, um, oh, who was it?
There's, like, another singer recently who was, like, doing a lot of clips.
Because she streamed, uh, after Lady Gaga's skin came out.
Oh!
That's interesting.
Wait, where do we at?
Let's get it, Donkey!
Let's fucking go!
We're gonna survive extra long again.
Okay, that's good.
Wait, did you rotate it really fucking good last game?
Yeah, we did really good rotate- when will we get middle of the zone?
This is not good.
Have we dropped now?
I know, right?
Wait, I don't think it is possible for us to get middle of the zone because we're at the side.
Where will we get, like- Oh, I can pull!
I can pull over here for sure.
Oh, yeah, where's our pull?
I wanna live in this house right here.
Are you being nice and cozy in there?
Yeah.
There's so many gliders?
Oh, that's you.
I wanna plant a tree.
We haven't got a single tree.
Oh, I will call the trees and we're gonna- I mean, like, I'm a walking tree, but planting one just hits death, you know?
Alright.
Yeah, tree planting a tree.
That's all we wanted.
Oh, I got the shocking thing.
Let's see.
Ooh, Pista.
Please don't shoot me.
Why would they shoot you?
They would never shoot a tree, right?
Yeah.
Wait, I found a tree!
Found one!
Let's go!
I got the tree!
Tree meta!
It's over.
It's fucking over.
I can't believe it.
It's as MrBeast as I found the tree.
That's like- It's like, I found two trees!
Oh my- It's so fucking over.
I literally found two trees.
Your personal walking tree is running up to you right now.
Oh my god.
The MrBeast buff.
I had zero trees going in for the last three games, and then on the fourth game, when I decided to be MrBeast, I find the tree.
It was meant to be.
It's like, MrBeast was meant to be a tree.
It was!
Is this- Oh no, it's a shield bubble.
Okay, I'm gonna get rid of this then.
See, I have the plunger.
Oh, you have the plunger!
And I also have the pistol.
Oh, you got the pistol too?
Oh, huge.
Oh, open that chest.
It's a blue- Oh!
That's what you need.
It's a pump.
Oh my god, it's a bunker!
You should have it.
Do you have one?
You don't want the shotgun?
Uh, no.
No, no, no, no.
I would not be using that.
What?
Oh, okay.
Alright.
And then you wanna grow houses?
You saw the houses work, right?
Yeah.
Should I grow houses?
You wanna grow houses?
Okay.
You wanna grow trees.
What do you feel like?
I have shield.
Okay, shield or...
I'll grow...
I'll give you the shield.
I'll grow a house.
I build a house and I plant trees.
The houses belong in MrBeast's inventory.
It's immersive.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Well, there's more trees here.
There's more trees here.
Oh my god, there's all the trees!
Yeah, we got so many trees here.
Oh my god, you know what?
I don't need shockwave grenade.
I'll have- Wait, maybe I do.
Maybe I'm getting a bit too overconfident here.
No, no, no, no.
Let the confidence out.
This is our time to shine.
You know what?
I don't need guns.
Wait, we gotta heal you.
I'm so dumb.
I did not realize I popped a big.
Wait, you don't have any shields.
It's okay.
I don't need...
I don't need a gun.
I need one gun.
Are there minis here?
Oh my god.
There's no heals here.
There's no heals at all.
I swear I dropped a mini somewhere.
I don't need heals.
All I need is a tree.
Let's go this way.
Because I feel like that condom team is gonna do the same thing.
Try to hold us out.
Oh, I see a chest up there.
Hang over there.
We're good.
I'm holding the trees.
Just in case.
As somebody that has no armor, I feel like I need to hold these trees out.
Yeah, if the moment you get shot, just throw the tree down on your feet.
Yeah, exactly.
This is why.
Oh, here.
I got minis.
I'm gonna toss them to you.
Wait, you can throw items?
Yeah, you can heal over there.
And I'm gonna toss that one.
Oh my god.
What the fuck?
Right?
You can throw.
Oh, I throw.
I'm a tree.
Okay, yeah, I know that, but...
Where do we go?
Alright, we're gonna go this way.
We're gonna go on top of the hill.
Ooh, I've never been to the top of this area before.
Right?
Because the condoms keep cutting us off.
They know.
They know we're right by...
I'm looking.
Tree, tree, tree.
You're good.
Look.
Oh, we're fucking chillin'.
We're fucking chillin'.
Alright.
Drink.
I'm watching.
I'm drinking.
This team's gonna force us to eat storm, I think?
It's okay, we have a tree.
Doggy, that was such a good reaction.
Keep doing that if we ever get shot at.
Oh my god.
Don't worry, I got you.
I have the tree out.
That was good.
I still have the tree out.
I was watching for the team.
Okay, oh.
I see them.
Chillin' there.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
We're good.
I don't think I have the meds for this.
Oh, they're fighting?
Wait, are they fighting someone?
Okay.
Follow my lead.
Stick to me.
We're gonna go to the left, okay?
Okay.
Ready?
And let's go now.
Don't worry, I have another tree if I have to.
Uh, we can technically eat storm still, but...
Yeah, let's go this way.
Let's go this way.
I'm gonna toss a little crash pad and we're gonna go to the side.
I'm gonna toss another one.
We're gonna go over here.
Oh, no.
And then there's a med kit here.
Oh, I need that.
I need that med kit so badly.
Take the med kit.
I need that so badly.
Oh, there's also a big pot here, too.
Oh, there's another med kit here.
We're good.
I'm okay.
We are Groot, chat.
We are literally Groot.
Oh, no.
I'll ditch it.
I'll ditch it for meds.
I think we're still chillin'.
We're chillin'.
Alright, and then we can start running up the hill here.
Don't worry, my tree...
Oh, I hear gunshots to my left.
Oh, team up here.
I'm gonna bubble you.
Oh, they poured a bunker.
I'm gonna cut to the left.
And we're gonna use the bunk or this.
What the...
Tree!
No!
It bugged me.
Play your life.
Tree!
Nice try.
I can't believe it.
It's okay.
I planted enough trees.
Honestly, I'm really, really proud of how you're playing that.
You're actually doing really good.
Unfortunately, I died to a bug, Doki.
Wait, what happened?
My characters, like, didn't teleport or didn't jump on the pad.
It, like, glitched me into the ground.
And then I had to run back on it.
And then...
Yeah...
I was like, well, GG's me.
How did they count in the tree strat?
I should've used my shock grenades.
Honestly, I think what we're gonna do...
We're gonna do what this team's doing.
You see how they're just living in storm right now?
Yeah, yeah.
We can live so long if we just prioritize, like, med kits and stuff.
Wait, really?
I think we're gonna do that.
Yeah, like, look how long they get to live out here.
Oh!
Yeah.
We're gonna definitely do that next game.
It's okay, guys.
We saved the environment by planting trees.
We planted, like, at least five trees.
Bro, they hate trees.
These guys hate the environment!
Cancel them!
They don't want MrBeast to save the world or Fortnite.
Exactly!
They could've let everyone just plant trees.
They also don't even want anyone to have houses.
They're buying?
Wait, what?
They did not have shields.
That's crazy.
They can shop?
Yeah, if you have enough gold.
I think they've been, like, getting a lot of gold from the chests.
They can basically just keep on healing.
What the fuck?
These guys are just healing!
I thought buying wasn't allowed.
No, buying's allowed.
You can get the gold each game.
So you have to literally start from zero.
Oh, I thought, like, I saw in the...
Maybe that's for day two.
Oh, that might be, um...
Yeah, tomorrow or whatever.
Yeah, I think that was day two.
I'll send Fortnite an email and tell them to make me a Fortnite skin.
Yeah, you gotta be your own skin and then they're gonna throw a little Chris's hat on you.
It's like, make me a Fortnite skin.
I would be a Fortnite streamer if you give me
a day two.
They kind of have my skin in the game.
There's a werewolf in here.
I usually like running the werewolf team.
And there is a day two, but we're not making it to day two.
Wait, isn't...
What if we actually do make it to day two?
Isn't day two, like, you gotta make it?
Um...
Do we have to play day two?
I thought day...
Oh, wait, no, I think we are playing day two.
I'm pretty sure.
Are we playing day two?
I thought...
I thought day two was like, we gotta make it.
I...
No, I think we're actually playing day two.
Wait, what the fuck?
But it's just the same game.
A whole number of first place finishes.
A whole number of elims.
Wait, why is there a day two?
Uh, it's gonna be on normal mode.
So it won't even be on OG.
It's just gonna be like all the...
All the, like, new stuff.
Huh?
Wait, I think...
Yeah, let's see, placement points are assigned.
Yeah, I think we played day two.
We played day two?
I don't see anything saying that we have to qualify.
Yeah, we literally just played day two.
But, like, what's the point?
Suffer more, Joki!
But...
It's just the same game!
Wait, what's the difference between day one and day two?
Wait, what, the build?
On day two, it's gonna be the current build of the game.
Cause this is like a special mode that came out.
Oh, this is three strikes.
Yeah, it's like three strikes, Mesa.
This is three strikes.
And then the other ones can be like regular.
Wait, so does the regular...
Does the regular also have bunkers?
Um, regular has...
It does have bunkers, but...
What's the difference?
There is way more...
There's like different weapons and different like movement items and all that stuff.
So, it's like a way, way different like style of the game.
I see.
Oh!
It's just no reboots.
Yeah, no reboots.
Alright guys, we're gonna plant more trees tomorrow.
Guys, I read the rules wrong.
I thought it was...
I thought like day one is like qualifiers.
And then day two is like if you don't qualify, you don't have to play it.
So, I was like, I'm not gonna qualify.
What I don't see is like...
I don't know like what place gets paid what.
Oh no.
Cause like whenever I played in Twitch Rivals, it's usually everyone gets like paid.
Yeah, no, everybody gets paid.
Yeah.
Oh, that's cool.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So, we just have to exist.
Yeah, exactly.
We just have to exist.
There's...
We get like literally $125 by just existing.
It's 125 McChickens.
Yeah, that's actually pretty good.
$125 just by existing?
And we're ha...
We're making memories.
We're having a good time.
We're literally watching houses get built.
We're watching trees get planted.
Exactly.
We're planting the trees.
And we're also doing it together.
Now I understand why the three Fortnite pros were like, I can't do two days with her.
Cause like, I get...
I like feel like one day then they're fine with that.
But like two days might be like a bit too much with me.
Never.
They just don't know how insanely cracked you are the moment that you get your time to shine.
Yeah, exactly.
This is just the beginning arc.
We didn't have time to shine yet.
We didn't have...
We didn't have our moment.
We didn't have a proper gun fight.
Basically get to just watch everyone else.
Yeah, we always got flanked.
And we're gonna thrive off of everyone else's energy.
Yeah, yeah.
Like we're gathering stats.
Like I'm literally learning how to play the game right now by watching others.
Oh, thank god.
Get rid...
Oh, what the fuck?
Holy shit!
Who is this guy?
I love that they're using the mammoth pistol.
That's that like revolver that they're using.
Oh my god!
That pistol's actually so good.
That guy's crazy!
Oh, never mind.
TG.
Get fucking comedy occurs.
That's fucking right.
Oh, it's my condoms!
The reboot's disabled.
Oh, it's the condoms again!
I feel like the storm doesn't hurt as much.
Why are they spamming bunkers?
Because that...
This is build mode.
I mean zero build mode.
Sorry, I had something in my throat.
He's gonna die in zone.
Where's he gonna live?
Oh, by building a house.
That sounds right.
Oh, condom down!
Condom down!
Woah!
He's just throwing their game!
Condom dead!
By the other condoms.
What the fuck was that flick?
He actually hit it too!
Yay!
Oh, this guy's actually one HP.
Oh my god.
Wait, why is he dropping a weapon?
He has enough slots.
Wait, why did he drop his weapon?
I don't understand Fortnite players.
He has enough item slots for this.
Oh?
Oh, they get to splash some HP?
He's dead.
There's no... yeah.
Oh, that's a skin I haven't seen before!
Wait, which one?
Oh, I I'm going to another team.
Oh my god.
They actually have not matching skins.
I like this team.
Wait, this is a team.
Oh, it's this guy!
They swapped skins!
Wait, which one?
Oh, is it the guys with the pink skirt?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They actually have skins that don't match.
Yo!
He actually had color in their skin.
That's crazy.
Seeing, like, actual color.
Oh?
The guy's gonna heal?
There's still, like, there's still so many teams.
What the fuck?
Oh?
I love watching this with you because, like, even though I know what's going on, it's why I don't play this game competitively.
Because the tick rate is horrible in this game.
Oh, is it?
And then, yeah, in, like, in zero build, it's literally, like, diet build mode.
And for me, I'm just like, yo, I'm not trying to play diet build mode.
Like, I chose zero build for WQ.
You really?
I wish you can just edit.
Like, the organizers just don't tell anybody.
They just edit the bunker to, like, one percent spawn rate.
I wish you could just do that.
Oh, that'd be so sick.
For one game!
For one game, they edit the spawn rate to one percent.
And I just wanna know what they're gonna do.
I wanna know what the players would do.
What do we do?
I can't build.
I can't build!
I can't believe it.
The place I landed had no bunkers.
Like, what is my luck?
And then everybody just doesn't know that it's not that they have terrible luck, it's that it just wasn't spawning.
Right?
It's like, my RNG is horrible, actually.
I'm rooting for this team.
The colourful team.
Yeah, the colourful team.
As long as they beat the condom team, that's all that matters.
That's all that matters to me.
Oh, they shotgun waving now?
Oh!
Oh my god, the reaction time for... and then they built a... they rebuilt the house.
Right?
They actually rebuilt the house.
Holy shit.
What the fuck?
Did they, like, shotgun wave?
The crazy thing is that this is only slightly sweatier than normal reload lobbies.
I wouldn't say slightly, like, it's definitely sweatier, but, like, reload lobbies are pretty sweaty.
They're, like, diet rank mode.
Oh my god.
Are they gonna shotgun him out?
Is that a shotgun wave?
Wait.
How come we can't do that together?
Oh, they're gonna...
They're gonna build a house.
Oh my god.
They did it.
They built the house.
Let's go, colorful team!
Oh, and they're destroying...
Oh, no.
They fucked up.
They missed that one.
Oh, yeah.
How do you hit it so that it destroys it?
You have to basically throw it at an angle where it's gonna connect with the player next to it.
And then it launches them out.
Oh, so it has to connect to the player.
Oh, so the launch breaks the house.
It has to be, like, an LOS.
Yeah.
Oh!
That makes sense.
Wait.
Somebody's living behind them.
There's people.
Oh, the squatters.
Oh, the squatters are gone.
Let's go, colorful team!
Yeah!
Colorful team!
Oh, shit.
Who the fuck shot him?
Yeah, right?
Yeah.
Who the fuck shot him?
Oh, shush.
Shush.
Get out of here.
Dude's shooting our pink...
Oh, no.
Don't worry.
They have...
He's holding a port-a-potty.
He's holding it.
Port-a-potty.
He's holding the port-a-potty.
I'm gonna start calling it a port-a-potty and a house now.
We'll back up.
Holy shit.
What the fuck?
No.
Is it condom versus condom?
There's one solo alive.
Wait.
Who's the solo?
Oh, the solo.
There's one solo non-condom team alive.
Let's see.
Wait.
Oh, is it non-condom?
Yeah.
We literally...
He literally has one...
Wait.
No.
It's actually a full team.
Yeah!
They did it!
The non-condoms won.
Let's go.
They had zone.
And they just built, like, several fucking bunkers to make their own building.
Dang.
What is that?
Three games out of five?
That, like, they're all non-condoms?
Yeah.
They're all non...
They're all non-condoms.
I mean, they still have small ass hitbox because they're playing, like, the girl skins.
But...
Yeah.
Maybe we should...
Our next team should be the girls.
Yeah.
What skin do you want to run?
Okay.
Wait.
What girl skins do we have?
I don't think I have any.
Wait.
Really?
I don't think so.
I think I...
All my skins are guys.
Because they're...
Wait.
Do you have any, like, furry character skins?
Let's see.
Because there...
There's some girl skins in that, too.
Wait.
I have Eevee.
Oh, I have her.
Adria.
And then...
Wait.
Put it on.
I don't fucking know.
Like, I don't know what this is from.
I don't know.
Oh!
I don't know what it is.
I have the 2D at 2.0.
She's...
She's from the very first season of Zero Build, I think.
Oh!
It's like when I...
I have Oscar.
I literally did not play Fortnite until Zero Build came out.
And then, like, I played it for a little bit.
And I was like, alright, there's tanks in this game.
I'm good.
I went back to Apex.
Oh!
You have Oscar.
I have Oscar.
Wait.
If you're gonna be Oscar, should I be the shark?
Should I be this guy?
Wait.
This is ZZZ.
Or should I also be a different variant of Oscar?
This is...
This is Doking.
I could be, um...
Oh, where's the other one?
Show me the tiger.
Oh, my God!
Is this a squad?
Is this it?
Oh, my God.
What the fuck?
Why are fucking hitboxes so big?
Oh, my God.
Bro, I don't know.
I don't know if I'm a hitbox, though.
I'm wearing a butter hitbox.
Alright, what...
Wanna be, um...
You wanna be the, um...
Hey, I have tomato, boy!
I have a classic!
Oh, be food!
Be food!
I have tomato, hey!
I can...
I can be a food skin, too.
Oh, my God!
Here, let me...
Let me swap.
Let me swap mine.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
I wanna...
I'm gonna be food.
Doking, you already be food.
What I...
Yes!
Wait!
That's so good!
Oh, my God!
This is so good!
Tomato and corn.
The perfect duo.
Where's my gritty?
Yeah.
Let's go.
Team tomato and corn.
Oh, my God.
Eat your veggies!
Eat your vegetables!
Eat your vegetables, guys!
Now I wish I had more Fortnite skins.
I could also be um...
Now that I have two days of Fortnite, I wish I had more Fortnite skins.
I'm about to literally just gift you some random ass cursed skins.
Now that we have each other added.
Oh my god!
Oh my god, I remember there's like this funky ass emote with these guys.
Isn't there?
You have it?
Oh, with this guy?
Oh yeah, you're talking about the one from the Battle Pass, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I saw it on Twitter.
Oh, where is it?
You have it?
I can't remember what it's called.
I do have it unlocked.
Yeah.
Is it this one?
Yeah, here it is.
We're eating protein veggies.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's this one.
Yeah, I saw it!
I saw the fucking emote.
I was like, what?
What the fuck?
Oh, did they have the code out yet?
Yeah, they just posted it.
Nice.
Okay, I was gonna say.
I was like, it'll be funny when you missed it again.
All right, we good.
We good.
All right, go ahead and ready up.
Nice.
Wait, what are you using for your...
Oh my god, two veggies.
What are you using for your pickaxe?
I'm using the poultry pummelers.
Oh, the poultry pummelers.
I'm gonna beat them up with meat.
Oh, is that the ones in the shop right now?
I don't think so.
I don't see in the shop.
I just had...
I bought it before for the Peter Griffin skin.
I have...
I have drumsticks.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
That's perfect.
Okay, I'm doing that one then.
And then...
Oh, what's my glider gonna be?
Wait, do you have the Peter...
Oh, wait.
I have the ice cream sandwiches.
The ice cream sandwiches?
Oh.
Yeah.
Okay.
My gliders are like...
I don't have a lot of gliders.
Not a lot of cool ones.
I have like a lot of Battle Pass ones.
I only...
Like my only cool one is...
Is literally like Shenron.
That's literally the only cool one I have.
Wait, really?
No, that one is cool though.
I have a car.
I like that one.
I'm gonna fucking...
Wait, you have a car?
You have Regalia?
No, I have like Victory Vaunter.
I think that was from the...
I also have the Woolly Mammoth.
The monster truck.
Oh, do I have that one?
The Woolly Mammoth?
I also have...
Oh, I have...
Do you have the inflatable horse?
The inflatable horse?
No.
What?
Yeah, I think it was like a Witcher.
It was like a witcher.
It was like a witcher unlock.
What the fuck?
The inflatable horse?
Yeah, I know.
I definitely do not have that.
Yeah.
Eat your veggies.
Everyone else is sweating and you two are having fun and vibing.
Yeah.
Eat your veggies, everybody.
Listen, Doki and I assembled literally an hour before the tournament.
Yeah, we were not ready.
We are vibing.
We accept our fate.
Doki was like the only Fortnite player that was like free.
I would say we're doing pretty damn good.
We're doing pretty good.
We're better than the Overwatch duo.
That's all that matters.
Let's go.
It's like, wait, where's the Mercy res?
Wait, there's a Mercy res?
No, that's what the Overwatch players are saying.
They're like, where's our Mercy res?
Where's our fucking Reinhardt shield?
Oh, that's so cute.
What's the other one that's similar to that?
Merry Christmas.
Merry Christmas, everybody.
Yay.
I got a P. I mean, are you using the bathroom?
Yeah.
How do P's pee?
Literally.
Do they even piss?
Oh my god.
Zoro.
Yeah.
I wish I spent more money on Fortnite.
You're gonna probably get random gifts from me now.
I like how I have like zero crowns.
Look at my zero crowns, everybody.
Yo, zero crowns?
Yeah, do you have the one too?
Wait, no.
I didn't.
I didn't buy it.
My bird is the worst.
No.
It's okay.
In spirit.
You have bird is the worst.
Yeah.
You do bird is the worst for me.
No.
Oh, I love this one.
What is that?
He like makes it pretty hard, I think.
Oh, no.
He just sparkles.
Nevermind.
Oh, there we go.
He does make the hearts.
Oh.
Oh, this is fine.
Wait.
That's such a good emote.
Oh, man.
I wish I...
It's so big too.
Oh, I wish I bought this.
Like, when you use it in game, it's ridiculous.
I wish I...
I wish I bought the Lethal Company dance one.
Did you buy the Lethal Company dance one?
Uh, yeah.
Do you have that one too?
No, I didn't.
I wasn't on Fortnite.
All right.
You're gonna get gifted the next time it's in the shop.
Wait, wait.
What does it look like?
Um, it's...
Oh, do I have it equipped yet?
I got...
Oh, here it is.
Oh.
It's so good.
I love it.
It's so funny.
It's so good on, like, all the skins too.
Yeah.
Like, every...
I don't think it looks bad on anyone.
It's gonna meet the quota.
We're gonna meet the quota, guys.
We're meeting the quota.
We're not gonna be in dead last.
Yeah.
What kind of...
I think it's Macarena.
What is it?
Just Dance?
Yeah.
I think it's just Dance.
Oh, my God.
Why don't we just get to Vibe here and just do all these emotes?
Yeah.
Everybody else is, like, fucking...
Like, strategizing now.
I know my place.
Oh, there's Chewbacca.
Wait, you have Chewbacca?
No, I can buy Chewbacca.
Wait, what do you have?
Do you have Han...
Do you have, like, Han Solo?
I think out of all the Fortnite skin collabs I have, I don't think I have any ones from Star Wars.
You don't have...
Oh, you don't have some...
Let me see.
Yeah.
Guys, it's Lego, but it includes Chewbacca.
Oh, no, I do.
I have, like, Darth Vader and stuff.
And then I have, like...
No!
You don't have Han Solo.
I have a Clone Trooper.
I have Ahsoka.
And then I have...
No, we can't match because you don't have Han Solo.
Is that it?
No!
Oh, do you have Princess Leia?
No.
No, I don't.
I don't...
Because you can buy Chewbacca right now.
Oh, wait.
What?
Oh, they added Chewbacca?
Yeah, they added Chewbacca.
You have to buy the Lego Pass, though.
Oh, that's where it's at.
Okay.
It's in the Lego Pass.
Yeah.
But you can, like, get it Chewbacca regularly.
Oh, I forgot to put on a back bling.
I'm sad.
It's okay.
I'm naked.
I'm naked on my back.
Look at all these condom people.
Is there any non-condom players in the lobby right now?
All right.
Cool.
We got our spot.
Oh, we're landing.
We can actually drop right away.
Okay.
Let's go.
All right, Chad.
Game number six.
Let's fucking go.
Wait.
Is it game number six?
I thought it was game five.
I think so.
Is it game five?
No, it's five.
Okay.
Game number five.
Let's go.
Summon the fucking dragon.
Wee.
Slowly drifting down.
All right.
Oh, nice.
I got crash pads.
Oh, that's good.
All right.
What's in here?
Oh.
A shotgun.
I got a shotgun.
Let's see.
They're all guns.
The moment I stop being Mr. Beast, there's no more trees.
It says a lot.
What the hell?
Trees?
It's actually crazy.
The trees just stop spawning.
I actually have zero trees.
Because we are the trees.
Well, we are the plant, I mean, or the food.
We're the vegetables.
Oh, my God.
It actually stops spawning.
The game knows.
Oh, hey, a sniper.
I'm outside your building.
Okay.
I'm trying to see what I'm...
Oh, there's one more.
Oh, there's a tree here.
Oh, my God.
One tree.
Yeah.
We got one tree.
That's all we needed.
Oh, I got more Gibby bubbles.
Nice.
We need that.
I'm going to drink my shield.
All right.
I'm going to see if there's any shields over here.
Oh, we're also in zone two.
We're...
Yay.
I'm doing good.
All right.
Yay.
Okay.
I feel like I might not be able to snipe here.
Everybody's always close range.
Yeah.
I've been thinking about what I'm going to run, and I think I'm going to swap up my weapon.
I have the crash pad.
Oh, you do?
Oh, same.
Same.
I have six.
Okay.
I'm just grabbing stuff over here.
I'm coming back.
We just don't have the porta potty.
We're just missing the...
How are we going to build a house?
I have four Gibby bubbles.
I have six launch pads and two shock waves.
You know what?
Oh, sweet.
Okay.
Day, look at...
You're a shock wave master now.
And trees.
And trees?
Okay.
Yeah.
Oh, I got houses.
We got a house?
We can afford it.
All right.
I'm going back to you.
Oh, my God.
Guys.
We are going to make it.
We have a house.
I think we have to just chill here for a little bit.
Yeah.
Oh, you know what we can also do too?
Were there med kits here?
There were like bandages, but not a med kit.
We might be able to lift Storm again.
We can do that strat.
Remember how that team was living forever?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm going to try that.
Did you grab the bandages?
Because there was...
No.
Let me check up here.
I know I dropped some.
We also have a lot of space to work with, and we can go all the way over there too.
But...
Oh, what do I drop?
There's a butt?
Do you want to...
I don't know.
Butts?
Ayo?
Do you want to build houses or do you want to make Gibby bubbles?
I feel like the house is stronger.
When I saw like 200,000 houses and like two Gibby bubbles, I feel like people were running houses more.
I'm going to drop the houses and I'm going to try to find some heals.
Because we also have to move too.
But we can also move with Storm.
We're going to like eat Storm because it's pretty fun.
Wait.
You're not going to pick up the bunker?
Or...
Oh, yeah.
I can pick it up for now.
Yeah.
Because like I'm going to try to find us med kits and heals, but we're going to go slow with Storm.
We're going to go at like 10 seconds.
Okay.
I don't think that team's going to come over from where we've died before.
Knowing them, I think they're going to rotate like all the way in the south.
So I think...
Yeah.
We're going to try to go back to looping.
Okay.
All right.
Let's start going.
Let's go.
Team veggies.
See, I see a team on the island, but we're going to go with Storm.
Okay.
Let's see.
Oh, there's team on right.
Let's crouch.
Crouch.
We're going to chill here.
Please leave us alone.
We're just poor little veggies.
We're trying to save the environment.
I also have a lot of jump pads, so that way we can keep rotating.
Not last.
Yay.
All right.
And this is going to be harder.
Let's go all the way out here.
You know that man.
Um.
How much gold?
I only got nine gold.
I have nine as well.
Okay.
We're going to hear...
Let's go in this bush here.
Come up here.
Okay.
We're going to look around.
Oh yeah.
There's definitely still team on the island.
So this is good.
This is good.
I don't have any meds.
We're going to find meds to the left.
We're going to go all the way over here.
What if we don't?
If we don't, uh, GG.
Cause like, your plan relies very heavily on the meds part.
This guy is also healing.
Oh no, what are they doing?
I think we're good.
Okay, let's go left.
I'm a little concerned, because woo!
I fell down.
I'm pretty sure I did find meds here earlier.
I'm pretty sure.
Oh, you fell?
Oh, here, I got a crossbow.
Here you go.
I think that should work?
Does it work?
No.
Goodbye.
Oh, here, I'll toss you a mickey.
I'm gonna toss you a mickey.
Goodbye.
Yay!
Wait, do you have enough heals, though?
No, I can find something, though.
I'll find something.
Cause there is, uh, a bunch of chests up here.
Oh, I got splashes.
Yeah, we're good.
Nice!
I'm gonna light a campfire.
And then I got more splashes.
Oh, there's more bandages!
Alright, so I'm gonna splashes once this thing goes out.
Alright.
Cause if I splashes now, it goes away.
Oh no.
We can live here forever.
This is our new home now.
We're drinking some, uh, some grape juice.
There's nobody here.
I can even... Oh!
Oh, what the fuck?
I cracked him!
I knocked him!
Okay, I'm gonna push.
I'm gonna push that.
He died.
Okay, let's go left.
Let's go left.
Oh, shit!
Oh, god!
I'm freaking freaked out!
I was like, where did he come from?
Where the fuck?
That was actually so fucking terrifying.
I was literally, I was literally trying to jam out!
Holy shit.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, Yogi.
That was fucking terrifying.
That was so funny.
Holy shit.
At that moment, I was like, there's nobody here.
I can finally emote and I see a guy next to me.
I'm chilling in Iva and this dude's running up like, yo, word?
I think we're good here.
I think.
There's a bunch of here I want us to get to.
Okay, I'm trying to head there.
I don't know if I can...
Oh, I fucking have a crown.
I'm so dumb.
Oh my god, again?
It keeps on respawning it on us.
Yeah, you have to, what's the word?
You have to, like, drop it, right?
Yeah, if I drop it though, people are gonna see it on the map, so I'm just gonna chill here.
Okay, I'm good.
I'm good here.
This is where he is?
What?
Um...
I'm gonna look around for him.
I'm in the bush.
I feel like there's gonna be a team on top of the tower here.
Not if I'm in the bush.
Hmm.
I'm terrified!
I don't know if there's heals here.
I'm so scared.
Dude, this buck MPS died like four times!
It won!
I didn't see him die like four times in this game!
Okay, Goki, I'm gonna try... we have to move forward.
Okay.
So, we can try to get over here?
Or we can get to here and build a house together.
Okay, I believe in the house.
I'm gonna go, I'm gonna go.
I'm gonna actually burn a bubble on this, because I need to see if there's heals on here.
Heals?
There's no heals.
No, oh no.
Okay, I'm going to your bush.
Actually, we go here.
Trying to ping what's in.
Someone is getting closer.
Is someone- I see the blueberry juice coming in.
Let's go this bush, let's go this bush.
Oh no, oh no.
Oh, there you go.
We're good.
I'm looking.
Wait, where did they shoot you from?
Over here?
I'm gonna go behind.
I'm okay.
Oh, are they in the bush?
I think they might be in the bush over here.
Where is here?
Uh, let's see if I can ping it.
Right there, I think?
Oh my god, oh my god.
Yeah, they are, they are, they are.
Where are they?
I'm gonna, they're, they're like hiding in there.
In that bush in front of us?
Yeah, they're literally in that bush.
What the fuck is wrong with them?
I, I wrapped all the way around.
Wait, where did you go?
I'm uh, behind you, I'm behind you.
Oh, there you are.
Okay, we can keep- Oh, actually, Goki, I have an idea.
Here, run back to me.
Yeah?
And we're gonna cut all the way to this on that.
Okay, I'm gonna toss a little jump pad.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Get ready and let's go.
Oh, I'm being fucking- You missed it, you missed it!
No, it's bugging me!
It's bugging me!
Okay, just keep going, keep going, keep going, keep going.
There we go.
Oh my god.
This game.
I'm going- Oh my god, it's bugging again!
I hate it here, dude!
I'm okay.
I feel safe.
Oh, I see them, I see them.
I'm okay.
Okay, I'm coming over.
I found bandages.
I'm here.
I'm gonna toss this down.
It's okay, I'm here.
I launchpad like two times to get here.
All right, we're covered on both sides.
We're good, we're good.
Okay.
I feel safer.
I'm just watching the other team behind us.
Holy shit.
Where is this RPG coming from?
Wait, is that an RPG?
Yeah.
Oh, I think I know where.
It's uh, I'll ping it.
I think it's right there.
I hear like- Vroom vroom.
Vroom vroom.
Doki, if we get pushed, I'm gonna immediately just shield bubble.
I'm gonna give you bubble.
Okay, okay.
I'm like, should I like come to you or be in this house?
No, no, you're good on that side.
You're good on that side.
All right.
Oh, oh, that's you.
Okay, I was like, who's that?
Yeah, I see a team that's fighting over here.
Wait, there's like a shield potion right in front of me.
Oh, there is?
Oh, that's good.
Okay, yeah, you can pop that then.
Okay, I'm gonna...
Yay!
I should probably not peek that.
They're fighting to our side?
I don't have an angle.
You can feel free to shoot whoever just so that way we have presence.
What's that sound?
Oh, that's uh, people responding, I think.
Oh, oh, the respawn's ending.
Okay, I was like, what the fuck?
Oh, we're like, we're good here.
We're literally chilling.
Yeah, I feel, I feel a little safer now.
We're chilling.
Oh, there's people in front of us.
Oops, I shot my house.
Oh, I hit that.
I randomly griefed this guy.
77 on someone?
Don't you love just griefing people in VR?
Is it safe for me to go up here?
I'm terrified.
I could get shot from there.
Yeah, I know.
It's so terrifying.
Um, can I peek this?
Oh, I can't even peek on the right.
There's so many people.
There's so many gunshots.
Come on, come out of the house, please.
If this bunker is safe, I'm going to...
Oh yeah, there were people here.
There's people gonna be right here on the left.
Okay.
I don't have an angle on that.
Yeah, you're good.
You're good.
Yeah, the only thing is she was in front of me and a little bit to the left.
If you get shot at, I can throw the bubble down where it can connect on your side of the building.
Yeah.
But, uh...
I think I'm fine for now.
Like, I still have this house.
Yeah.
Yeah, we made this house.
It's our house.
Oh, they're coming out of the house.
Oh wait, never mind.
Okay, so we are gonna have to move.
Um, but...
Okay.
I think...
I have one house I can build.
All right.
We can try to get over here, I think?
I feel confident with that one house.
Actually, Joki, come to this side of the house.
Because I think what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna make a...
Launch pad?
Oh!
Wait, how do I...
Wait, you go inside the door!
No, I'm gonna die from this door here!
There's a door here!
What the fuck?
What the fuck, Dorian?
You didn't tell me to fucking open the door!
I can't!
Okay, we're gonna have to go, we're gonna have to go, we're gonna have to go!
No, we're gonna go!
I'm gonna die now, Dorian!
No, you're gonna live, you're gonna live!
I'm gonna die!
Oh, you're good, you're good!
I got you, I got you, I got you.
Ah!
I got you, I got you, I got you, I got you, I got you.
How did you tell me that the door...
Alright, so this might be a GG, so I'm dead.
You just said, go!
I was like, okay!
I didn't realize you can't climb!
No!
There was a door on the other side!
I can't tell, there was a door!
I got so confused!
I don't know if you can climb.
My favorite part about that whole scenario is that you could have literally walked inside
Oh my god, I'm fucking crying right now.
That was so funny.
I can't see the door!
Oh my god.
I can't realize, I get so scared.
Guys, we gotta kill, guys.
That's all that matters.
We got one kill, we ended on 50.
You know what?
No, no, Doggy, we have consistency, okay?
Yeah, we have consistency.
You know what these things don't have?
They don't have consistency.
Exactly.
We're never last.
They're not ending on the same number as we are.
Every single round.
We're 15th place Andes.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, the houses are real.
I swear, we died to the Christmas team so many times.
Yeah, they wanna wish us Merry Christmas in July.
Why are they always next to us?
I swear, it's like they know.
They're like...
Look, these guys are the different people who keep on becoming other skins.
Yeah, they know.
They fucking know.
That was the fucking best one of them, Joe.
They know that's us.
Holy shit.
I'm literally crying, but like, my cheeks hurt from laughing.
That was so fucking funny.
I wonder what it looked like on their stream.
They tried to climb the house and get knocked off.
Wait, are they alive still?
Are the Christmas people alive?
Yeah, they're still alive.
Wait, who was it?
Oh, wait, wait, here, here.
I don't know.
They're anonymous.
Yeah, we don't know.
Oh my god.
I wanna watch their POVs so bad.
They're gonna be like, why is this guy running outside?
I didn't know there was a door.
Wait, what the fuck?
He threw a trophy at us.
What the fuck?
Oh my god, they died in one...
What?
They fucking closed my eyes and they're dead.
That is some OG ass thing I've never ever seen.
What the... what is that?
What are they holding?
What is that?
Like, they're holding a giant, like, a giant trophy.
What the fuck?
And then they, like, throw it?
I've never seen this before.
That's how, like, not OG I am.
Like, what are they doing?
What are they doing with the trophy?
I think they have one-shots.
Oh, it does 200 damage in one hit.
What the fuck?
How did you get the trophy?
BuckFPS is still alive?
This man has died, like, this is the fifth time I see him die on the kill feed.
How is he still alive?
I wanna watch this guy get a kill with this.
Are they just, like, is BuckFPS just landing on somebody and just his other duo is just, like, waiting until, like, he respawns?
Like, what's the strat?
Like, he keeps coming back.
Oh, is this guy gonna live?
I wanna see him throw the freaking fish at someone even though it's a condom skin.
Wait, that's so risky.
Like, yeah, he's so dead.
Just throw it now.
Oh, he's dead.
He's dead.
No, you guys threw it!
How the hell, man?
No!
Throw it!
He could've thrown it!
You're dead already.
Just throw it.
He knew he was gonna die anyway.
Yeah!
Oh my god, thank god.
No condoms.
Thank god.
Let's go!
No condoms!
One condom team has won throughout this tournament.
Chat, you hear that?
Condom skins don't help you.
Yeah, they don't help you.
And you don't have fun.
You will never have fun if you have it on.
That's my favorite comment in chat.
It ain't much, but it's honest work for a one kill.
Oh shit, sorry.
Out of context, by the way.
I did not mean it like that.
I'm freezing.
Oh no!
STDs is a problem.
Oh, I'm fucking dying.
I'm dying.
Oh my god.
I'm making it worse.
I literally cannot.
I cannot right now.
Toki, I didn't know I was gonna literally die of laughter.
Oh my god.
This entire tournament.
This tournament.
Tournament.
Wait, what's our thing this next one?
What are we gonna be?
Oh yeah, last one.
Yeah, it's our last one.
And then we have day two tomorrow.
Okay, then we have day two.
Okay.
Then we have day two.
I could play like...
Wait, do you have any Futurama?
Oh, I do.
I do have Futurama.
I have Bendy.
Okay, I have Leela.
Okay, yeah, yeah.
Oh, you don't have Fry?
No!
I do.
No, I do have Fry.
I have Fry.
Oh, Fry and Bendy!
Let's go!
Okay, okay, okay.
I'm down, I'm down, I'm down.
Fry and Bendy.
Okay.
If Fry and Bendy, I'm gonna get a golf club.
Yeah, we gonna be pay to lose looking at.
Have you ever seen how big these freaking skins are?
Yeah.
They are so ridiculous.
Let's go!
Oh, my God.
Let's fucking go.
Are we winning?
Oh, we are totally winning.
We're winning in life.
That's all that matters.
We are consistent on our placement.
We got one kill last game.
Pay to lose.
What are you?
I'm gonna use the stop sign.
I'm running out of skins for tomorrow.
Do Fortnite skins change hitbox size as well?
No, I believe they're all the same.
There might be like three different like variants, I think.
There's like the very chonky big skins.
Yeah.
There's like the normal male skin.
That's why you see all of them use those.
Use that same fucking skin over and over again.
Giant Chicken or Riot?
We were already Giant Chicken.
Yeah, we did Giant Chicken.
Somebody wasn't watching.
Yeah.
It's there.
Look in the Vaude.
I love you.
I don't.
Fuck you.
Potato's gonna go like cry, cries in corner.
Yeah, cry.
I'm gonna use a giant inflatable horse.
This is the win team right here.
This is it.
I believe.
Last game, guys.
This is last game and then we'll be free until tomorrow.
Oh my god.
Are you ready for tomorrow?
Are you ready?
No.
Today was just a warm up day.
Today's just a warm up.
Wait, you haven't played this season, have you?
No, of course not.
Dude, this... you're in for a treat.
There's so much, I guess.
Holy shit.
In the current season.
Alright, after this game, we gotta play one like chill lobby.
I'm down to do a chill lobby.
I'm down.
I wanna know what it feels like to actually shoot my gun.
I don't...
Where have you shot?
No, you shot your gun once, right?
Yeah, I shot my gun once last game, but still I wonder what it feels like to like shoot more than one time.
Like, you know, get a kill, you know?
I wanna know what it's like to be top five.
I wanna know.
Oh, we are gonna get so many top five.
We're gonna get a top one.
Oh, they haven't posted the code yet.
Oh, they haven't?
Thank god.
Alright.
Oh, they're typing it like right now.
Oh, I can ready in advance.
That's good.
Thank god.
Oh, yeah?
Oh, shit.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, okay.
They have... Oh, wow, you're right.
They did add Lady Gaga back in.
Yeah.
I didn't even notice that.
Oh?
Wait, they stopped typing.
Doki, are you gonna be a Fortnite streamer now after this tournament?
If I get a Fortnite skin, I'll be a Fortnite streamer.
You hear that, Fortnite?
Yeah, Fortnite.
You hear that?
Doki's skin or Riot?
Yeah.
If you don't...
Imagine, imagine the money you'll make having a VTuber skin.
They have no VTuber skins yet.
Yeah, imagine.
Imagine.
I am all in all for VTuber skin and some furry skin, even though they already have a lot.
The fuck?
Don't listen to him.
I just want... I just want my skin.
Doki or Riot.
Yeah.
I just want my skin.
I can't believe that guy had a... a golden flopper or whatever it's called.
It's like apparently really rare.
Yeah, that's what like... that's what peeps were saying.
Yeah, yeah.
I heard everybody's like, oh, yeah, that's so rare to get.
And then like he threw that trophy and the guy just died.
Like, it was like blunt head trauma.
We got to like watch one person die to it.
Yeah.
That's all that matters.
It's fucking crazy.
We witnessed a murder.
Like, we witnessed a lot of murders, but like that murder was like extra gruesome.
Are they streaming the tournament right now?
Like...
Well, I mean, it's a Twitch Rivals, so...
Oh, yeah.
Twitch Rivals.
Yeah.
Did you forget we're in the Twi...
Like, what are we playing?
I saw that it was like State Farm.
Like, you can think...
I wonder if State Farm is streaming.
Oh, we got the code.
Okay.
We got the code.
Nice.
Guys, I want a Doki Fortnite skin.
I have children watching me, even though they're not supposed to.
I found out.
There was a child...
There were children at my panel during a convention, so I know they exist.
And Fortnite was having...
Oh, was that one that Rikikonzi did?
Yeah.
One of my conventions I did, I was like, I hope there's no children here because I'm going to swear.
And then it was like Q&A time, and then they gave a microphone to a child that was like 11 years old.
Oh!
Because I was like, how old are you?
And he's like, 11.
And I'm like, fuck.
And he just like shriveled into a like very, very shriveled up reason.
I was like, oh no, children should not be watching me.
I wonder if Twitch Rivals has shown us like surviving.
If they want content, they got to like be in our call.
I wonder if they're going to jump into a listen-in on us, and they're going to hear this.
I was being like, oh, there's condoms over there?
There's condoms over there?
And we're the Cocomelon of VTubing.
Yeah.
That's me.
Guys.
Wait.
What skin are we going to be?
What do we are?
What do you mean?
We literally...
Are you okay, Doryu?
Are you?
No, I'm not okay.
We're literally the characters.
Everything's on blur.
How?
I don't know what's happening.
I'm Doki Mellon.
Guys, we gotta...
Wait.
We gotta let...
We gotta let Fortnite go.
And Fortnite know that we do have children in our audience, because Fortnite loves knowing that there's kids watching us.
Because that's...
People who spend money.
As apparently...
Wait.
They watched us when we were Morty Under The Bridge?
Oh my God!
When we were what under the bridge.
Remember we were Morty and...
Oh, we were...
and Mr. Misty.
Yeah.
Misty and Morty.
They're watching us.
Nice.
All I'm saying is that, guys...
Oh, they're showing the same thing.
Oh, they're starting this.
Oh, no.
No, we don't want to watch that, Doryu.
You don't want to watch that.
No, we're going to be in 15th.
I'm calling right now.
We're going to be in 15th.
I saw somebody mention that we were last at one point, so you don't want to watch it.
They're capping.
They obviously were not in last, you know.
Obviously.
We've been playing out of our minds.
Doryu, no.
It's going to break your heart, Doryu.
It's going to break your heart when you see it.
Yo, we're only two points behind the other teams that are behind us.
Or in front of us, I mean.
Like, there's three teams that have eight points, and we have six points.
Wait, we have six points?
We have six points.
How did they get eight points?
I literally see J3 die first, like, 200 times.
That's because we're consistent on not dying.
What the fuck?
Oh, they get kills, because we're just doing placement, but they have kills.
Oh, that makes sense.
That shouldn't make sense.
It's not fair.
There's the people around us are like the sweats that make it to top five every time.
Is it really?
Yeah, we have the condom people and the Christmas hats people right next to us.
Oh, you're right.
It is the Christmas hat people.
It's the Christmas hats and the condoms.
It's not fair.
I wonder, since it's the last game, if we're going to get, like, ego sent on.
Maybe.
For the points?
Yeah, they're probably going to be like, hmm.
We killed one of them last time, though.
That's true.
Oh, I have Macarena.
All it took was you to be like, wait, there's someone here!
You're going to be literally locked onto them and just destroyed them.
Wait, let's sync up the Macarena.
Okay.
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
Ready?
Oh, you're go, you're go, you're go.
You should do the count, you should do the count.
Three, two, one, go.
Yay!
Da-da-da-da-da-da-da.
And Macarena!
I was like, a second off, a second off.
Da-da-da-da-da-da-da.
Da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da.
And Macarena, hi?
Ha-ha-ha!
..c bench, to please have lunchout.
Yeah, no one can do it like we can.
Yeah, at least we're having fun.
Yeah, what are those guys doing?
Not having fun?
Exactly!
They're too busy strategizing.
We're peak Fortnite gamers.
Fortnite's not about sweating, it's about skins and dancing!
Yeah.
That's how they got 5 million followers!
And RP servers where you emote with Chun-Li and...
The richest Fortnite streamer!
All they do is dance and buy skins.
We embody the real Fortnite gamers.
We are playing for the people.
Yeah, we're the people!
We're the Fortnite's people.
You think the children are building 500 houses?
No!
They're out there being fucking Bender!
They're literally Bender and emoting.
Yeah.
And being every Jujutsu Kaisen.
Jujutsu Kaisen skin variant.
Exactly.
While playing Fortnite Festival.
Use my creator code, DokiBird.
Oh, I have that too!
Oh, you have that one?
Yeah, yeah.
Wait, do you have the My Hero Academia skins?
No, I didn't.
I just bought this.
I just...
I wanted this with John Cena.
That's...
Oh, my God.
I did not think of that combo.
That's actually terrifying.
I bought this emote just for John Cena.
For the people.
For the symbols.
What is happening to my eyes?
We're gonna plant trees.
We're gonna plant trees and burn plastic.
Yeah!
Because it's all about the balance.
What the fuck is that?
What the fuck?
I love how everyone has that same reaction with his emo.
I had the same reaction when I first saw him.
Like, what the fuck is he riding on?
Yeah, what the fuck is that?
Like.
Oh, yes!
Ballerina dancer meadow, right?
Rock and roll?
This is how you dance on the metal, right?
Dabababababa!
Dababababa!
What the fuck?
By zero...
This is the world that we grew up in.
Zero.
Yey!
Does this reset every bad, like... season?
I know I've won for it!
Fortnite games, like...
Oh yeah, it resets every season.
Okay, I was like, why did I have zero crowns?
It doesn't even cover my hair.
Wait, it doesn't.
Yeah, the umbrella.
That's got a big ass head.
Go Doki, give us nothing.
Chai Peppers.
Wait, what is this one?
I don't remember having that.
It would be nice if I had a crown.
Obviously, Chai, we're gonna kill the whole lobby.
Yeah, yeah, now this is different.
This is different.
Oh my god, there's condoms all around us.
Oh my god, wait.
This guy, I've never seen these guys before.
They must die before they could do anything.
Oh, I see you.
Oh, did you drop your crown?
I did, I did.
Nice.
Nobody wants to join our band.
They know we're losers.
We were cool before they even knew what the word cool was.
All right, let's get...
This is the one.
All right, let me know when to land.
Okay, I'll... let me ping it.
And then drop... now.
All right.
Yeah, oh my god.
You got the floaty.
The floaty floaty.
Yeah, I got the little floaty floaties.
Yay, Bender has summoned Shenron.
All right, here we go again.
I'm gonna laugh.
These guys are gonna probably shockwave on me one day.
Like right now.
Oh, I got a shockwave.
Oh, I got trees.
Oh, I got shockwaves.
Let's go.
Tree time.
Oh, I got more shockwaves.
I'm getting faster at looting.
You can see each game I'm improving.
Dang.
See, they don't even know.
Again, oh.
Yeah.
They're trying to push me.
Wait, are they actually?
Yeah, they're actually pushing me.
Wait, that's not good.
Wait, guys.
I am gonna do this.
Guys, let's play the game.
Guys, please.
Let's play the game.
Shockwaving?
These guys, I knew they were gonna be so horny for me.
Right here?
Oh.
Where are they?
They're on my bunk.
Wait, where are you?
I'm on your rooftop right now.
I'm gonna loot.
They're not gonna kill me, right?
Yeah, no, no, no.
They're gonna kill Fry.
Yeah.
I'm gonna loot.
They burned your three jump pads, so...
I'm just gonna kill them.
I have a- those, like, Splash juices.
Okay, yeah.
Once you just loot everything, I'm gonna chill on the rooftop.
I'll tell you if they push your anything with that.
Okay.
I'm ready.
Stop pushing?
Are you still chilling on the roof?
Yeah, I'm still chilling up here.
I'm just watching for them.
I must smash Splashes.
Ow, yeah.
Splash.
Yeah.
There's a shield potion here.
Oh, there is?
You'll keep grab that?
I'm gonna chill up here.
I'm gonna keep watching for them.
I'm pretty sure they just like ran.
But we're gonna like...
We can eat some storm and we can literally wrap all the way around here.
Or we can swim all the way around over here.
Okay.
We're living this.
We're living.
Yeah, we're survivors.
The president peaked again.
Oh, I see a condom scene down there.
Wait, where's the shield at?
Oh, I can drop it.
Okay, okay.
Here, it's on me.
Thank you.
Honestly, we can probably just go...
We can go in the water now.
Here, follow me.
Alright.
We're gonna eat storm.
We're gonna...
I have bandages, so I'm fine with that.
You got bandages?
Sweet.
Okay.
I'm gonna laugh.
This guy's gonna be in the bush right here.
I'm calling it right now.
No, please don't.
Please don't.
Please.
Please, I'm scared.
I'm just a robot.
I'm just a little robot.
At least you got bandages.
The only thing you gotta make sure of is don't heal until we're away from the scene.
Okay.
Cause it'll show an indicator when we're healing.
Oh, wait, really?
Yeah.
Oh, like the sound?
Yeah, it's all for the sound thing, yeah.
Oh, so that's why everybody has it on.
Yeah, yeah.
It'll show that and then you can just see all the footsteps and stuff.
It's really, really good.
Oh.
We're still good?
Bucky buck FPS.
Guys, kill this duo!
What is he doing?
Oh, I got bandages.
We're good.
Okay, we can heal here.
We can heal here.
There's some pads here if you need movement.
Oh, yeah, I'll take that.
We're living.
I feel alive.
I feel so alive with my 40 HP.
Oh my god, I see a team out here.
Okay, chill inside.
Chill inside.
We're good.
What did they hear?
Heard me bandage.
They're all the way across?
No, I don't think they saw.
I don't think they saw.
I see one.
Wait, they definitely see us.
Almost cracked this guy.
I'm just gonna slide to the side.
They're bunkering.
I see them.
They're in the bunkering, yeah.
It's fine.
I just wanna apply pressure just so that way they keep on, like, moving.
Oh, we got a med kit.
Okay, I'm bandaging.
Okay.
I'm gonna chill on the roof.
What are you doing?
Leave!
We have not enough meds for you!
Keep on looting the house.
Yeah, come over here to this house.
And then we can see maybe there's seals over here.
Oh, they just bunked again.
Stop wasting your resources!
So real.
They're right there?
You're gonna get nothing from us.
Oh, they threw a med kit.
Okay, well I'm gonna have to heal.
I have more bandages so you need some.
Okay, just keep on holding onto those.
You can play that angle.
Okay, I guess not.
They might push.
I'm watching.
You can heal.
Yeah, it's fine.
I just popped the med kit.
I'm good.
I'm good too, I think.
I'm gonna get on the rooftop.
I'm gonna non-stop heal.
There's another launch pad.
I'm gonna grab those.
Yeah.
We can shockwave away.
Wait, they have the crown?
What the frick?
Timing?
Okay, I'm gonna shockwave to the right.
I'm gonna go right.
Okay.
I'm gonna try to get ahead of them so they don't wrap around us.
Should I come over?
Yeah, come on over.
Come on over.
Wee!
Oh, I fucked up.
Woo!
So, I'm just trying to find some heals.
We can actually go through here?
Those bandages.
Okay.
Oh yeah, there's bandages.
There's bandages.
Oh, do you need shockwaves?
I'm good.
There's a heal here.
The little campfire.
Do you have a gold for it?
No, I have zero.
I didn't realize you need money.
Okay, you're good.
Oh, I have a med kit.
Okay, yeah, just go ahead and heal on that.
And then we're gonna have to like run into storm on the... or run from storm on this next one.
Oh, there's a chest here.
Oh, I found bandages?
Sweet.
Oh, I found splashies.
Oh, huge, huge, huge.
Okay, you can just use them on yourself.
Okay.
And then I'm gonna have bandages for us.
Oh, I have gold too.
Oh, we got med kits here.
There's med kits.
Oh, I need those.
Okay, I'm gonna toss it your way.
And then come out from the cave over here.
What are you tossing?
Just come towards me on this side.
Okay.
Then I'm just gonna toss it here at the edge.
And then before you use your splashes... I already used it.
Oh, you did?
Okay.
I'm gonna use those first.
Where's the med kit?
It's to the... it's right below.
Right here.
Oh, okay.
Wait, where?
Oh, it's right here.
I got another one.
Oh, it's right there.
Okay, I got a splat time.
I got it.
I can get it.
No, no, no.
I'll toss you another one.
Come and go.
We got 30 seconds or we're gonna have to start going.
I think I see a team over here.
Okay, med kit.
Med kit-ing up now.
Okay, I'm gonna med kit too.
Oh, I see a team literally on the edge.
No, leave us alone.
Where's this next zone?
Oh my god, this zone pull sucks.
It's not until we eat, I think, 500 storm damage that it starts doing storm sickness.
So we should be okay.
Storm sickness?
Yeah, that's where you start taking increased damage rapidly.
What the fuck?
Okay.
Okay, there's gonna be a team on the other side of that mountain, but we should be okay down here for now.
I'm all running over.
I'm scared though.
Okay, we're gonna go left?
Oh, there's...
Is nine gold enough?
No, it's I think 50.
God damn it.
Wow, no one is dying this game.
Please don't tell me that was to me.
Okay, I'm gonna shockwave over here, Doki.
Okay, I need to heal a little bit.
Okay, I might be able to just run in.
I had to heal.
Yeah, you're good.
You're good.
Why is everybody playing careful?
Oh, there's nobody!
Oh no!
Are they shooting you?
Jump yourself or launch yourself.
I'm looking.
No, no, no, no.
Oh my god, there's a team here.
Oh, respawn, respawn, respawn.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, live!
Live!
I'm living, I'm living, I'm living.
Just live!
I'm living.
You're gonna be good.
Just live!
In five, four, three, two, one!
We're good!
Wait, I should've just died in the room.
Oh wait, no, I have nothing.
I didn't realize you lose everything.
You can land on the house.
Land on the house right there.
The one I pinged.
Okay.
Please be nobody, I'm just Bender.
Alright, I'll let you know if there's people in here.
Alright.
There's nobody here for now.
Where is this team at?
They're like, in storm?
Jesus, I'm hearing all of these fucking noises.
I'm going in.
Oh, it's ending in a minute.
I'm here with you, I'm here with you.
Oh, we inside this.
Alright, I wish I could give you heals.
I'm gonna give you the jump pads for now.
Okay.
Don't worry, I have 500 guns.
Ayo, you got 500 guns?
Oh, you need ammo?
No, I'm good.
I have ammo.
Okay, next zone is...
Do they have 200 RPGs?
Oh, team coming over?
I think?
Where?
From which direction?
I hear people here?
Wait, this seems on top.
Mount 90!
I don't have SMGs.
And a rifle.
I'm trying to like, see what I can like, what we can play.
We can go this house.
Okay.
We're gonna try to get to the blue house, okay?
Okay, how do we get there?
Let's burn a shockwave or your jump pad to get over, okay?
Okay.
Get to the blue ping.
I'm gonna ping, or I'm gonna go now.
I think there's actually a team in here, but I'm going in.
Oh, I see a team outside.
Okay, I'm safe, I'm safe inside, I'm safe inside.
I got medkits too.
Oh, he saw me, they saw me.
You're good, you're good, you're good.
It's the Lara Crofts.
They saw us, they saw us.
I think they're gonna try to push us, 100%.
I'm just waiting for the bubble to go down.
It's gonna go down in 3, 2...
Oh, no, nevermind, they tossed another one.
It's gonna go down in...
3, 2, 1.
I don't see them.
Can they burn another one?
They burned another?
Yeah, they're just trying to prolong the...
You know how B and B are, they're just trying to live.
Yeah.
I see them, they're running to our left, they're running to our left.
Okay, this is good, this is good.
We're chillin' inside, we're chillin' inside.
I see them, I see them, they're to our left right now.
Okay.
They might try to get to here.
On the roof, I think they went to the roof.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
They should theoretically get shot at by...
Oh, they're underneath, they're underneath.
They're gonna try to climb on this.
I think we're getting shockwave down?
What's this?
Oh, they're climbing, they're climbing right here.
They're right here, right here.
Okay, watch, watch the staircase.
Okay, I'm gonna go underneath, go underneath, go underneath, go underneath.
Come, come, come.
What the...
Oh, I'm trying to move.
Oh, sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
Okay, we're good, we're good, we're good, we're good.
They're getting shot, we're getting shot.
They're getting shot at.
Oh, God.
Knocked one, knocked one.
Nice.
I'm thirsting for you.
I'm thirsting.
I got the thirst.
It's okay, I got the thirst.
I'm jumping, I'm jumping.
Please.
I'm good.
I got the first for you.
Yeah.
I got the first.
Let's go.
Just live.
We have a boy.
I'm moving.
Just live.
Oh.
Shit.
This isn't good.
Oh, that's another team.
That's a full team.
Live in the bush if you can.
Live in somebody's house.
Oh, good.
That's a hustle.
Yeah.
Oh, there's a point.
There's a point.
You get a point.
No.
You would get a point.
You would.
We got a point.
I was trying to get the other one.
Yeah.
Oh, my God.
We got a point.
That's not advantageous.
Yo, Doki.
We placed 13th.
We got 13th.
We did better.
Proved.
Wait, you killed the guy that's in first?
That's a victory?
Wait, what?
What?
Oh, no.
You're saying that's a victory in general.
Okay.
Oh, no.
We killed somebody.
That's a victory.
Yeah.
We got randomly rocketed.
It wasn't even the same team.
Wait.
Really?
No.
We could've got two parts.
I didn't notice our second kill.
Yeah.
Because I was like, no.
There's the three of you.
Bro.
They should remove rocket launchers.
Remove bunkers and rocket launchers.
That's all I want.
Random RPG moment.
Is there a special rule for killing the first place player?
Let me see.
I don't think so.
Because he still lives.
He's the one that got Doki and Storm?
Epic revenge moment?
Yes.
Let's go.
Nice.
Fuck them.
Yeah.
Eat a wiener.
In game.
Or IRL.
That's your thing.
I love how you like broke into that guy's house just to kill him.
That's fucked up.
That's so fucked up.
His father was like, leave me alone bro.
I'm just here.
Let me see the rules.
Let's see.
Format.
See total number of players in the event.
Blink.
Oh my god.
There's only one condom team.
Thank fucking god.
Wait.
Only one condom team?
Yeah.
There's only one.
They learned.
No.
JK.
There's two.
I'm sorry.
One.
The other guy's a solo.
Wait.
No.
What?
How is this...
What the fuck?
Hey.
They have high ground.
How did they always have zone?
This is not fair.
These guys are...
They're on a sub.
Oh, wait.
What the hell?
Oh, that's a...
The POI.
I was so confused by that giant metal structure.
Wait.
Is that POI?
Or like no.
It's like an iconic thing, I think.
What's it called?
Yeah.
Cause there's a llama.
It's a llama!
Oh, that's what it is!
It's a llama.
Yeah, it's a llama, so it has to be part of the structure.
To kill the number one player that makes you number one?
Yeah, that should be the case.
It's true.
Oh shit, they knew he was in the bush!
That's so smart.
Once you play the game long enough, you eventually just never trust bushes.
You're like, I hate bushes.
Oh!
Oh, that's the number one player, I think.
Oh, he's dead!
The one that just died.
Oh, yeah, fuck that guy.
I'm watching the...
I should not give the condom people views.
I'm watching the plunger.
I'm watching the plunger people.
I'm watching a grandma team right now.
Oh my god, they're growing trees.
They're planting a tree.
What's going on here?
Thank you for the real updates that I care about.
Hey, yo!
What's in the item shop?
Are there any cool emotes?
This thing I actually care about.
Oh?
I'm watching our red-headed team.
I'm watching the plunger team.
They have the plunger gun.
They're the ones that has a push.
Oh, the guys with the push!
I think these guys have won a bunch.
They won like two games back to back, I think.
Did they?
I can't tell.
They're all the same.
They're all the fucking same to me.
They're all in novice mode.
Get out of the novice mode, you fucking pussies!
Who's stream-stiping you?
Who?
I'm telling you, you're literally the...
You're the voice of the people now.
Oh, they're getting pushed by a condom.
I'm 5 HP.
Oh, they're getting pushed by the condoms!
No!
Not the condom, kids!
I'm watching the grandma team again.
Oh, the grandmas are dying.
Oh god, not the grannies.
No, let the grannies live!
Oh, granny's dead!
Oh, the granny team's dead.
To a condom again.
Oh shit, it's like red-heads versus condoms.
And just one guy.
Just one solo.
That, out of context, sounds so good.
Oh my god.
Oh, big brain!
Oh, but they're dead!
My god, this guy's level 445?
That's a Fortnite player right there.
What is this guy, level 167?
I'm watching Thies right now.
Isn't he an OG Fortnite player?
Oh, who is?
Thies.
Oh, Thies?
Everyone's a noob.
I can't even spectate them.
No!
It's okay.
Get out of my screen.
I'm not even gonna watch your dance.
Oh, he said Thies.
I'm so dumb.
I thought he said Feast.
No, no, T-H-I-E-F-S.
Yeah, Thies is actually really good.
He's like one of the players I knew when I saw the list.
We want your feedback on a scale from 1 to 10.
How would you rate 1?
I strongly disliked it because the condoms won.
Negative 69.
Alright, let's play one game.
Oh my god, we get to play a normal game!
Let's go!
I want to be Mr. Beast.
No, I want to be John Cena.
You want to be John Cena?
Who do I play as?
Play your dream as content.
Let me play as...
I can be a big cat man.
Alright, let's see.
John Cena with the pom poms.
Yeah!
John Cena.
Thanks for the reminder again.
I forgot.
Oh!
Oh my god!
They added so many emotes.
Oh my god.
They added emotes that matter to me.
What's this?
Oh!
They let him go!
They let Cena go!
Oh my god!
Okay.
Alright, wake up.
What's this?
Alright, I know which one I want.
I know exactly.
Pirates of the Caribbean.
Okay, they did not refresh these.
Oh, what the fuck?
Is that a monkey?
Hey, yo!
Wait, what?
Oh, I didn't see the rest of the shop.
There's like a monkey.
Is that it?
Oh, the stock monkey.
Yeah!
There's a monkey.
So ugly.
Okay, I know exactly what I want to buy.
Oh my god.
Pew pew.
Okay, so we are playing tomorrow for sure, I guess.
Regardless.
Yeah.
Dang, look at us.
We made it through to day 2.
I'm proud of us.
Oh my god, we did it.
We fucking did it.
We did it, day 2.
We made it through.
We made it through the day.
Alright, I got new emotes.
Let's see.
Let's see, where is...
I want to see what the standings were for the end.
Did that one point matter to us?
Did it?
Well, like, I wonder if we actually got another, like, more points than the other teams that were ahead of us.
Yeah.
They were only ahead of us by like two points.
You're a duck.
Oh my god.
Oh, you want to see the... this is what I bought.
Oh, you have that one.
They had mine, they had mine.
It's called Gunsinger, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Pew, pew.
And I have this too.
Oh, look at him go.
Let him go.
Go, Sina, go.
Show those moves.
Oh, don't see what's going on.
Look at him.
Let him go.
Go, Sina, go.
Oh yeah, there.
I forgot to ready up.
Oh, I forgot about that.
I forgot about the actual part of the game.
No, we're playing the game right now.
Oh my god, now we can actually play the game.
Wait, okay.
Oh my god, what would it look like on...
Okay, I'm proud of us.
We got 13th on our last game.
Yeah, we improved.
We're consistently improving.
That's all that matters.
One of my really, really goated Fortnite buddies was like, I know 90% of that lobby list and you guys did really good.
I told you.
My bodyguard.
Oh yeah.
I told you I'd block all the bullets with my big body.
We did it.
I'm not fluffy for any other reason.
We got our bodyguard.
Mixi!
Hello, Mixi.
We're continuing on the trend of condom skins.
Alright.
Nice.
Oh my god, I get to actually play the game.
I get to actually play the game.
Holy shit, I swear to god, if I see a fucking bunker person, I'm going straight up to them and shotgunning them in the face.
Yeah!
Let's fucking go!
Let's go!
I played against Fortnite pros today.
You don't matter to me.
You are nothing.
You're beneath us.
Oh my god, you have pom-poms!
I do.
You're all beneath me.
I fucking played against Fortnite pros.
Who carried ten buildings.
Bottom.
Who is this loser with thirty- Fifty-eight crowns?
Get out of here!
Get the fuck out of here!
Fifty-eight crowns, you loser!
We're in DC!
That's fucking right.
My crown.
Damn.
They were like, nah.
Nah.
Alright, I'm ready.
Alright, where do you want to go?
Where do you feel like going?
Please tell me where you want to go.
What looks cool to you?
I don't know.
Uh, yeah, railways.
Let's fucking do it.
Oh my god, it's going to be so spicy.
You see that icon on the map?
The skull?
That's like the best medallion in the game.
And it randomly spawned over here.
So we're going to have a hell of people here.
Holy shit.
We can kill them, right?
Oh my god.
Why are my frames dropping like crazy?
Holy shit!
What the fuck?
I destroyed the first spot!
It's not even coming to us!
I killed one!
Come on, I'm with you.
I'm scared.
Yeah!
Freaking die!
I killed one.
We're good, we're good.
Wait, is there loot on you?
Is there loot on you?
Uh, there should be, yeah.
Okay, I'm just going to head to you.
Knock knock!
John Cena, he's here.
John Cena!
And his name is...
I got ammo.
Oh, they ran, okay.
And I have...
What the fuck is this?
I have Nitro Splash?
Is there a gun?
Oh yeah, I have a Mini-Tree.
And then here's the ammo.
Nice, okay.
And then once you're done popping those, stand next to me and I'm going to hit these canisters here.
Okay, I'm just going to grab this gun.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And this too.
Alright, I'm good.
Where the fuck is this gun that you got me?
Flint, knock, pistol.
Okay.
Okay, so let's hit these.
And then I'm going to do this.
And you can run forever.
There you go.
Oh shit!
Oh!
JazzDV!
Get shit on!
Yeah, this team's dead!
Oh my god, what the fuck is happening?
Get fucking...
Where are you?
Where the fuck are you?
Where are you peas?
Where is the peas?
Where is he?
Oh god.
Guys, what?
Oh, I'm pushing him.
I'm coming over, I'm coming over.
Oh, I'm pushing that ass.
I'm going in, I'm going in.
I got lost.
There's too many doors.
How do I get out of this house?
Life has too many doors.
How do I get out?
Fuck away, chest!
We're alive!
We're good!
We're good, we're good.
Everything's fine.
I don't know what guns I'm holding, but everything's fine.
You're not like... You're like owning right now.
We just fucking own some of yours.
Yeah, that's right.
Get fucking shit on.
I need this.
Can I eat my apple?
Ooh, I'm gonna break in.
I'm gonna steal some gold.
Ooh, I'm gonna steal a cabbage.
Can we eat some cock?
Do you need any, like, ammo for your flint knock?
No, I'm good.
Yeah, I'm dropping that.
How many bullets do I have?
Is this one bullet, one shot?
Yeah, it's like a one shot, but it acts kind of like a shotgun.
And it also, like, launches you into the air.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
That's what I felt.
I was like, what the fuck?
Oh, is that what was happening when you were fighting him?
Yeah, yeah.
I was, like, fighting him.
Oh, you got people?
That's fucking right.
This guy's one?
Knocked one?
Nice.
Get over here.
That's fucking right.
Get out.
Where is he?
I cracked this guy?
No, I missed!
Yeah, that's why I was like, no.
I'm gonna try shockwave.
There we go.
That's good.
Oh my god, I'm actually one HP.
Holy shit.
I have cabbages.
You want cabbages?
Yeah, yeah.
Don't bring cabbages.
Okay.
Thank you, Dawn Cena.
You're my favorite.
Don't worry.
I'm here to feed you.
Don't worry, little duck.
I'm gonna feed you some cabbages at the lake.
Alright, let's go to the left.
Alright, I'm fucking going.
I'm going.
I'm feeding some ducks at the pond.
We are fucking owning.
Way better than these guys could own.
Yeah, that's right.
Alright.
Let's keep going left.
This is a shotgun run and gun harbinger SMG.
Is that good?
Uh, the harbinger?
Yeah, what color is it?
Green.
Yeah, it's not too bad.
That one's actually got like crazy buffs.
I think like a few patches ago.
Oh my god, I'm listening to twitch rivals in the background.
I have the nitro splash.
Oh yeah, nitro splash.
Is that the?
That's the one that you splashed on me, right?
Yeah, that gives you like infinite sprinting.
Oh, okay.
Here, I'll give it to you.
I don't want that.
No, no, you should use it.
I don't know what I'm doing.
All you gotta do is use it and then you start going really fast.
Here, I can split it with you.
There you go.
Alright, sweet.
Alright, I'm gonna pop it and we can start sprinting.
Alright.
Let's fucking go!
I could destroy the fucking bush!
Yeah, you can literally just run through stuff.
You like break through everything.
Oh shit!
Yeah, right?
John Cena's here!
Holy shit.
That's crazy.
Oh no, I don't have it anymore.
I think it was a 10 second shot.
I think that's like 10 seconds.
Wait, somebody's here.
I hear footsteps.
Oh yeah, that might be them.
Holy shit!
Run to me, run to me.
I ran too far.
You cracked one?
Nice.
You guys won?
I cracked the other guy?
Knocked him?
18?
Where is he?
They're dead!
There's another vehicle here.
Nice.
Alright, give me your shit.
Give me your shit.
Give me your fucking shit.
Oh, you have...
What is this?
Oh my god.
What did you throw at me?
I'm gonna swap my flint gun.
I don't want it anymore.
I'm done playing with you.
I don't want to play with you anymore.
I got a sniper now.
I cannot wait to find the movement item of the season.
Because you're gonna be like, What the fuck, League of Legends?
Have you ever played League before?
No.
Oh, you haven't?
No, I still have a life.
Tell him.
We're gonna get in here.
We're gonna go for a little drive.
Okay.
I'm heading over.
Yo, you're gonna drive your own car?
Wait, wait.
Oh, you're right outside.
Where did he go?
Nice.
What the fuck happened here?
Look, it's all broken.
Wait, you're right.
What the fuck?
I just feel fighting.
And they have the medallion.
Okay, we don't have any movement.
Other than our infinite nitros.
That's enough movement for us.
Yeah, we're gonna kill you.
We ain't no pussies.
Yeah, we don't have anonymous mode on.
That's when you know we're gamers.
Okay, I'm gonna get out of here.
Get out of the car.
We're gonna chase this dude.
Sorry for calling you pussies.
They're right here.
Yeah, we're gonna kill these dudes.
He's fucking running.
Stop running, bitch!
Stop running!
Oh my god.
Oh shit.
I'm gonna reload.
We're good.
I don't have an angle on them.
These guys are just kinda...
They're just being really annoying out there.
There's people behind us, I think.
There's people behind us?
Yeah, they're gloving away.
I might be fucked then.
No, we good.
I'm looking back.
I'm gonna run back the way that we came.
Okay.
Because I might...
I'm looking.
Help me.
Oh, he's so low.
I knocked him.
Where's his buddy?
Oh, I'm gonna come to you.
John Cena's gonna live!
John Cena did not live.
Pick up!
Pick me up!
I have bandages on me.
Oh no.
John Cena, please.
We're gonna lose.
I need to be the people's champion.
Okay, we're good.
We're good.
You can heal.
I have bandages.
Okay, okay.
I'm gonna toss you.
Yeah, I'm gonna catch it.
It's like baseball.
Where is it?
I tossed it...
Oh my god, it's so far.
I'm gonna toss you a big shield.
Okay, got it.
After you're done.
Oh my god, we're alive.
We're still alive.
We're still healthy.
Oh, they're shooting.
They're shooting.
They're still shooting.
Damn.
We can full top off over here.
Let's go back over to the train station.
And then we're gonna top off.
Let's go!
Let's fucking go!
John Cena wants to eat everything.
I think.
This is legal, by the way.
This is legal.
I'm drinking legal stuff.
Oh shit, we're out of bigs here.
I have heals.
I have gold.
Oh, you do?
Yeah.
Okay, pop another one then.
Oh, it's out of stock.
Oh, I thought you meant like...
I thought you meant like... that's...
Yeah, I was gonna like...
See, you call them shield bads too.
I fucking call them shield bads.
Oh, wait.
They're coming over.
What the fuck?
Are they driving you?
Yeah.
They have a machine gun on top.
Oh, they're gonna keep running, I think.
What the fuck is wrong with you?
Oh, they're gone.
They're gone.
I thought it was a drive-by.
Alright, well, I guess we can keep looting here.
I guess we can keep looting here.
I can't believe we don't have any movement.
There's actually so many movement items in this game.
Yeah, like what kind?
They have these gloves.
Oh, the Magneto?
They have the Magneto gloves.
Oh!
Oh, they came back.
They're leaving!
No!
Where are they shooting at?
The wacky inflatable guys over here.
Alright, well...
Let's try to find...
I wanna like top off on heals.
I can't find any.
Yeah, I can't find any either.
Is there any down here?
I only found like bullets.
Wait, what gun is that?
Laser rifle.
Oh my god, this place is so dry.
I got distracted into every match?
Woah.
Oh, that thing's hitscan.
That's what I like to hear.
Where do we go?
Let's go...
Let's go this way.
Oh, I can't ping.
Alright, well, the ping system sucks, but I'm trying to ping over here.
I'm just gonna follow.
I follow.
Let's go John Cena.
John Cena.
Don't worry.
John Cena never dies!
Kaleigh, Brenna, Nitro.
Do you have Nitros?
Yeah.
Okay, cool.
Oh my god, we can run on water!
We're Jesus!
Oh my god!
Just like Jesus, my hero.
I fucking knew he was Jesus.
The almighty, powerful dug-on to Simgun.
Oh wait, more Nitros?
Uh, there's Nitros in here if you need.
Nice.
Okay, what is this?
There's a repair?
Oh, that's for the car.
Yeah.
Uh, we can actually drive...
Oh, here, I got an idea.
We're gonna try to get some movement.
Grab those Nitros.
Which one?
Oh, I don't know why he keeps picking up the shotgun.
Yeah, I got it.
Okay, I'm trying to un-ping that.
Okay, there we go.
We're in the cart.
Yeah.
And then let's go... let's go over here.
There might be some movement over here.
There's also stuff we can heal on.
Like these.
Okay.
Wait, does that heal you?
Oh, the cactus!
Yeah, it heals you!
Oh, wait, that's so cool!
Yeah, so like that, the cactus, they regen in the desert area.
Yeah.
And then, uh, desert area I think has a higher chance of, like, spawning the gloves.
Oh!
So I'm gonna check over here.
And see if there's anything.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, 16 seconds.
We're also pretty close to zone 2, so we don't have to, like, run for 5 ever.
Ooh, and a Nitro drone!
Okay.
Alright, let's get out of the cart here, and then we can just, like, run around here.
Let's see.
Oh my god.
This place is sick.
Right?
What the fuck?
These were one of the medallions falling down too.
This place is fucking sick!
Whoa!
What the fuck?
What's that?
Does that hurt you?
Uh, the flames?
No, they launch you up.
Oh, the flames?
No, I'm talking about the fucking spinning.
Oh, the blades or whatever?
Oh my god!
I got a house!
You got a house?
I got a house.
It's happening.
It's over for the fucking over.
Okay, there's, like, no movement anywhere.
We have real estate.
Alright, well, at least we ran through there.
Oh.
This is what we're gonna be playing on tomorrow.
Okay, oh, this map?
So people are just gonna...
Wait, did you claim a spot for tomorrow?
Uh, no.
Wait, can we actually claim those right now?
I don't remember.
We gotta look at the rules.
Yeah, I'll look at the rules and then I'll see if I can claim something.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Am I basically a VTuber?
No, I'm a werewolf IRL.
He's a werewolf.
He used to be, when I met Doryu, he used to be a fleshy, and he got bit by a wolf in between, so I don't know.
I was like, yo, being a fleshy is cringe.
He got bit by a wolf, so now he's a werewolf.
I know a wolf that also knows a wolf, and then they also know another wolf.
Wait, are they all werewolves?
These things also are gonna give us the nitro, too.
Oh, shit.
Nice, we're super fast.
And then, uh, do you want the shockwaves?
Do you wanna keep practicing with those?
No, I'm good.
Okay.
I've already mastered it.
I didn't need any more.
There's a tourney coming up?
Uh, so we're doing day two of the tourney.
Today was, uh, day one, and then tomorrow's day two.
But we were doing on, uh, reload.
Yeah.
I thought...
I thought day two was when you qualify.
We did qualify, we were just zoning.
Oh, it's true, true.
Guys, we qualified for day two.
That's how good we are, guys.
Oh, you wanna get the bomb?
Only 24 teams can qualify to day two.
And we made it.
Wait, what?
Hey, so you don't take fall damage with this either.
Yeah.
So you just jump from here.
And there's Baja Blast down here.
Oh, there's Baja Blast?
What does it do?
Yeah, like walk into it.
And then look what you do.
What the fuck?
You literally become Tracer.
Wait, how did you do that?
Uh, it's a double jump.
Whoa!
And every time you touch the Baja Blast, you just get, uh, you get the dashes.
Wait, how long does it last?
Uh, it lasts forever.
It'll stay on you as long as you have the charges.
So, you only get three charges.
Oh!
Okay, Baja Blast time.
Dude, Fortnite changed so much.
I know, right?
Wait, there's someone here?
Where?
Knocked one?
I knocked a Wolfman!
Where is he?
I killed him.
No!
I don't know where Sivir is, though.
Where's his teammate?
You think you can get away?
I fucking have Baja Blast.
Yeah, tell him!
Fuck him up!
Yeah, that's right.
Oh my god, he has Nuka-Cola?
What the fuck has the Nuka-Cola done?
Uh, so that does, um, it heals 75 shields, and then I think it heals, like, 50 HP.
I think?
What the fuck?
What is Father doing here?
Yeah.
They have Fallen?
When will they have Doki Bird?
They're throwing.
They gotta, they gotta add Doki.
So, what's that?
We need to teleport you over here, Mixxy.
We're gonna teleport you to NA.
Where, where is...
I hear gunshots.
Uh, gunshots are on top of the hill?
They're over... here.
Let's go.
Alright, let's fucking get it.
I don't like them.
I don't like them either.
I don't even see what they look like, but I definitely do.
Yeah, I don't like them.
I'm gonna kill them right now.
They're in my lobby.
I already hate them.
I'm gonna nitro here.
Where?
Can we run up here?
Yeah.
Oh, what the hell?
My character is teleporting.
Whoa, whoa.
Alright, I'm gonna nitro this again.
And then...
I don't think we can.
I'm gonna shop it.
No!
Oh, did I shockwave you off?
Did I shockwave you away?
No!
They ran the baby away.
Oh my.
I'm coming down.
These guys are...
No, they are hand-holding like crazy.
Moments before disaster.
These guys have all the movement.
And I'm just a little dude.
I'm just like, they have...
They're hand-holding.
I looked at them and I died so fast.
Holy shit.
I am going to...
Yeah, I can grab your card.
I can grab your card.
What is this teleport?
I keep lying teleporting.
I died so fast.
Yeah, I literally was up here, about to fight one of them, and then they literally both handheld on me.
I was like, what is happening right now?
It's okay.
I have 200 seconds.
I got you.
You got me.
I have Nitro too.
I have Nitro.
Get my Discord Nitro.
I got your Discord Nitro.
We're going to live this.
Oh my god.
Oh, are they fighting?
Yeah.
It's so safe.
This is the slowest... This is the slowest res ever, but we're so safe.
No!
Okay, guys.
I'm proud of y'all.
Oh my god.
You're fucking nerds.
Holy shit.
That movement though.
Oh, wait.
They're fighting now.
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
No, they're camping the res.
That's fucking right.
Die.
Where?
Is this guy above?
Oh, I see them.
Oh, they thirsted him.
Wait, is that medallion good?
Uh, it gives me unlimited ammo.
But, uh...
I don't think it's going to be what will save him.
Oh, the glass!
Is that good?
Yeah, it's good.
It's good.
Holy shit.
What is this movement?
What the fuck?
You literally traveled across the map in one second.
Right?
I told you the movement in the other freaking...
The other mode is so cursed.
Oh, no.
This...
This is going to be tomorrow.
Oh, we are...
Oh, I get it.
I get it.
I'm proud of you.
I'm proud of you, dude.
Oh, no.
Wait.
Is the hands going to exist tomorrow?
Uh, yeah.
I think so.
Oh, no.
Oh, my God.
It took the whole game to find gloves.
Holy shit.
Oh, my God.
We got to... We got to deal with that tomorrow?
Yup.
Oh, wait.
They said hands are not in rank nor are cars.
Oh, thank God.
Oh, okay.
So they're not going to have that.
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
That's...
Thank God.
Okay.
Oh.
I really... I don't think I would like to play.
I don't think I'll have fun.
With the pros?
The pros with the hands?
I don't know.
Oh, don't... You got hands.
That's what they don't have.
They don't have hands.
Oh, Jesus Christ.
Thank fucking God.
GG's.
I had fun.
GG's, Dokie.
What a great day one.
Thanks for dropping by, like...
Yeah.
Like an hour before the tournament.
I really appreciate it.
That's a blast.
Like, I was actually joking with my boyfriend about how, like, I have this luck with Fortnite where I will always get pulled into something very last second.
And I'm like, you know what?
Fuck it.
We fall.
I'm just gonna... I'm just gonna go all in.
Fuck it.
Oh, thank God.
Yeah.
Thank God.
GG's.
GG's, Dokie.
Yeah, I'll see you day two.
I miss your face.
It's been a long time.
It's really...
Yeah, let me know if you want to, like, play a bit, too.
Like, before the tournament or whatever.
Yeah, yeah.
I think I do.
I think I definitely need to warm up.
I will.
I'll figure out how to drop spawn stuff, too.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Alright.
I'll see you later.
Bye, Dokie.
Bye.
I adore you.
Bye, everyone in Dokie's chat.
Bye, everybody in Dory's chat.
Oh, my God.
That was so fun.
I had a fun time.
Um, being...
Like, just playing with Doryu and just, like, being dragged around.
I realized, wow, Fortnite changed so much.
Um, thank you, everybody, for watching.
I guess tomorrow, also, we're going to be playing Fortnite tomorrow for day two.
Um, so, uh, there's going to be more of the tournament with Doryu.
Uh, so if you guys want to check it out, it's going to be same time, 2 p.m.
PST.
Uh, on Twitch.
Um, it always happens.
Every time, like, I'm resting, uh, there's a Twitch Rivals tournament that I get invited to, which I think it's... it's happened a lot.
I realize...
I realize it has happened frequently, quite a lot.
Like, it's a pattern.
But... but it's been really fun.
I've been having a great time.
Um, just wanted to...
Um, I haven't talked to Doryu in a long, long time, I think.
Yeah.
Like I said, I knew him back in Apex.
Um, he was, uh, still, like, a fleshy.
Uh, now he's a werewolf.
Now I have a werewolf bodyguard.
Um, but I'm glad that... I'm glad that, like, we had somebody to play... play Fort... like, do this Twitch Rivals with.
Cause like I said, we went through, like, three different Fortnite pros, and then I'm so happy that Doryu was able to, like, uh, sub in at super fucking last minute for us.
Um, and, uh, like, and with Twitch staff helping us too.
Uh, but yeah!
I really appreciate everybody for coming in!
If you guys don't know me, my name is DokiBird.
Um, I usually stream on YouTubes, but today I am on Twitch for the tournament, usually for Twitch Rivals.
I am, uh, on Twitch for Twitch Rivals, so please check me on YouTube.
Um, you guys wanna know whenever I stream on... on Twitch, please follow me on Twitter.
Uh, we have a lot of promo stuff.
We have...
you guys know my gamer subcode?
Uh, check... you wanna support me via other means?
I have so many other ways to support me from...
with, like, uh, gamer subs, the Hyatt merch, the merch store, um, and thank you everybody for all the subs, the gift of subs, uh, the biddies, and the follows.
I really, really, really do appreciate it.
As always, everybody stay hydrated, pause, check it out, and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you step for me, head to bed, cause you deserve it!
I'll see you guys next time, everybody!
Bye, guys!
Bye!